We're good.
Roy Wood jr. how are
you sir? Man, pleasure.
Pleasure to have you on here man. And
when you shake fun of these guys alive.
I don't solutely you are
just trying to pay bills.
Probably one of the funniest
guys out there, man.
I'm very excited to have
you in here. Foxconn.
And we were talking shit
about Apple and electronics.
Apples fucking you out here. So
got the new back book right and the new
Mac book with the new OLS or whatever it
is. It doesn't fuck with the
old versions or final cut.
The old video editing software.
I used to use new Matt but goes you got
buy that shit again. I'm like my n***a,
I just paid for that shit a hundreds of
dollars with my last computer and now I
got to give you, you telling me
my old software, no good. But the,
and you could make the software work
with the new O S if you want it to,
but they don't want to get you to
mind again and all that shit so dirty.
So now I'm having to learn Adobe
premiere. I was pretty good.
But final cut but I'm
having to swap out and yeah,
I've got to relearn a whole new thing
and if I'm going to do that then I may as
well relearn a whole new
piece of electronics.
But to do that means I
have to gut everything.
That means you have to gut the Apple
TV, you have to let go of the iPhone,
you have to let go of the iPad.
My girlfriend had the whole house.
The companies get you. So everybody in
the house, even my son, he had a Samsung,
he had a Samsung tablet and I was
like get that shit outta here.
You had to get you a iPad. So we re
gifted that and then got in my eyes.
So it's like nah man.
Fierce about that Mac versus Android
shit as much as they do about like
Republicans versus demo [inaudible]
I want something where I don't have to
keep paying for the same shit over and
over again every three, four years.
Apple makes great shit, but they fucked,
the interface is so smooth. It's so
convenient. I can check text messages,
I can do whatever I want on my Mac
book. Yes, I can talk to my television,
I can one click and all the app pay
and all of that stuff. It's beautiful,
but in three years it's
time to pay up again.
I almost switched over
a couple years back.
I bought a pixel and the pixel two came
out but then when it came out I couldn't
get text messages and I had a,
I got an email Apple and ask them to take
my email address off of the I message
database in order for you.
I'm like take that email off so that I
can't get I messages anymore and it still
didn't work. I went online to
try to figure out what is a way,
how do you get out of this? How does
this work? You can't, no. And if you,
unless you switch over to text message
for a long period of time beforehand,
like switch your iMessages to
text messages on your Apple,
on your phone or unless
you buy a new number,
you got to kind of buy it is if you're
going to get an an a Samsung phone or
something, you gotta
get a new number. What
got you, what, when did you make the
switch to Apple in the first one second.
What was the thing forever?
But what was the Genesis?
At some point you had to have had like
a Sangio 59 that was my old flip phone.
Shout out to CGU. Um, I remember
when I was in radio, uh,
back home in Birmingham, I
was gifted an iPod touch.
Oh yeah. And I was all Android
phones, Android, everything.
And I had an iPod touch and at the time
all I had to play music was the mini
disc player. So I could only hold
like five hours. I mean, this is like,
Oh one Oh two and I had a five
hour minutes and I go, fuck it.
I'll carry around the iPod touch
and then it made more sense.
Why am I carrying an iPod touch and an
Android phone when I could just have an
iPhone that does both. And
that started the journey.
I started with iPhone one but
before that I was using Mac books.
I was using Mac forever. But
even before they had an iPhone,
I used to make my own PCs or used to
go to the store, like go to Fry's,
buy a motherboard, buy hard
drives all time for that.
That's a it you gotta you gotta want
to do that? Like it was for me. I was,
I wanted to find out
how to do it and it was,
it was cool to play games on a
computer that I put together myself.
But then you knew how to like, so
you're building the games as well.
Are you going out and buying
the floppy disc and all that?
Um, I'm not definitely not building
any games. I would just, you know,
like I'd buy video games,
just play them on this,
but even format in it
and doing everything,
I would have to call friends that really
knew what the fuck was up and they'd
have to talk me through shit.
There's some things you'd have
to do in the bios and you know,
the irony of all of this is that I still
have an AOL email address as much as I
bitch about it. Really? Yeah,
I know. And you know what?
I don't understand email slander.
It's like my fucker. It's,
I'm sending you words electronically.
Does it matter what company?
What does it need? Is
my email more ghetto?
Does it come with chicken grease
stains when you open it in your lap?
No,
it's the same words that if I send it
from Gmail now I have a Gmail account so
that people will take me seriously when
I emailed them about business ideas.
But I still have an old school AOL email
that I've had since college and I'm
like, it's fine.
It's a one. It's one of those things
though when you just don't let it go.
And just think about you've got mail.
You remember when you first heard
that you've got [inaudible].
They were happy. [inaudible]
someone want to talk to me.
It was very exciting to talk to me and
then you get older and you realize what,
please leave me alone. Who the
fuck is this? No, God. Male. Yeah.
It was exciting. It was like a new thing.
That was 96 that's when I
got to five. Yeah. Yeah.
95 96 we had an old CompuServe account
at the house and that was how we got
online and then we started getting
the AOL disc and all of that shit.
We had a Compaq Presario too.
Oh, I had one of those.
I had one of those.
I started out with one of those old Macs
that was like a beige box member with
[inaudible]. Yeah. I don't
remember what number it was,
but it was 95 94 somewhere around there.
I don't know.
That might be like the O G Mac book
where the keyboard in the CPU was its own
little, like heavy.
No.
You had a keyboard that had plug in a
monitor that you had to plug in and it was
like a tower. I was like a
beige funky looking tower.
It was slow as shit. It was
14 four modem. Come on. Yeah,
14 four I remember when you got
56 cat. I couldn't believe it.
Look at the speed a, wasn't that Jamie?
It was a a monitor. Didn't have
the floppy disc built into it.
I don't think it's hard to remember.
I remember it being, there was a,
an actual tower and it wasn't a joint
where the whole computer was like the
monitor itself or the computer on CPU all
together.
No, but man, I thought I
was living in the future.
I couldn't believe something like that.
Jamie bro, my older brother had. Yeah,
that one on the far
right. That was it. Moda.
I had a Mac book, man.
It had an old school Macintosh and in
90s and he had Microsoft flight simulator
and you couldn't tell me shit. I
go to his house for five hours,
would just fly assessments
in real time like I get it.
I get why people will sit down with the
flight simulator and fly in real time
from LA to San Francisco, seen the
new ones they have. Oh, it's unreal,
but pretty neat.
I would need to buy a PC and then
I knew I wouldn't get shit done.
Have you ever used the HTC
Vive? No. Oh, what's the one?
What is it? Virtual reality. We
have one here. Oh, the whole helmet.
Sit down joint dude.
My kids come here and they battle
to the death to see who gets the VR.
They fight each other. Punching,
kicking shit. It's amazing, man.
You put this thing on and like
you're in another world. You're,
you're fighting zombies. You're in
the ocean with, with, with whales.
I went to a Samsung event and they had
some AR type experience where you put the
phone on and it's fun. But then I just,
I don't know. In the back of my head,
I can't get, I can't get out of my
head how goofy I look to someone else.
So it's almost like
something I gotta do alone.
Yes, you look goofy, you look
really goofy when you play.
There's a boxing game though,
that you can get a great
workout in like a legitimate,
great workout because
this dude comes at you,
you see me throwing punches
and every time he hits her,
you see a bright white spark. You feel
like you're getting hit. It's wild, man.
You're moving around and bobbing and
ducking punches, throwing combinations.
If your feet start hurting,
right, your hands get tired.
Is that going to catch on for real,
Joe? Is this like the Nintendo?
We when it first came out,
no, he's getting bored.
You're going to lose calories with the
Nintendo wee and then you're just a fat
bastard on the couch and learning how
I learned how to bowl sitting down with
the we
Ken, you can get in
shape with this for real.
Like if you wanted to do multiple
rounds of boxing with this thing,
you would get in some serious
fucking shape because it feels real.
When you put that headset on and you're
that dudes in front of you and he comes
towards you and he's got his hands
up and then throw a punch. It's like,
Oh shit, and you're moving
around. He's swinging at you.
You see the punches flying
over your head. It's awesome.
Now, this isn't something
that's predictive in a sense,
or is it like different types of
workouts at different types of sparring
sessions? Because eventually you can
predict if you knew the patterns,
it's still a workout.
Yeah, it's a good workout, but either
way you're fucking this dude up.
That's the whole idea. The whole
idea is to keep it on them.
It's not like you hit, you don't
feel anything. If he hits you,
you just see the spark
that's next. Ain't no,
they'll have a vis that vibrates it and
then it gets electrolysis and, yeah,
yeah, yeah. There's a haptic
feedback vest that you wear.
There's a place called the void.
He'd go there and as a star Wars game
and the storm troopers are shooting you
and they hit you in the chest.
He feel like my shit hurt.
Like does it hurt or is it like
just a sensation? Just a sensation.
Like laser tag. Yeah, exactly like it,
but it'll get bores. Yeah. It's again,
they're, they're doing
these warehouses now.
When you go into a warehouse and it's
all virtual reality and so they have
everything planned out and like
you walk on a cross as beam,
there's fire to the left you and fire
to the rights. You feel heat. It's all,
it's gone now. That's dope. They
have it set up to make it, you know,
really sort of mimic whatever
sensation you're supposed to.
No, the guy that I would be, I
would be all in for, you know,
when I was listening to you coming up,
like you started talking about the
sensory deprivation chambers and I'm like,
that's always been something that's in
the back of my head if we want to do it.
It's like, do you have any time
today? You could do it. Um,
I don't know how much time I have
after let, let's see. It's it, I know,
cause I know it's a mind fuck. It's a
little bit of a mind fuck. Yeah. But it's,
it's, it's one of those things
where I go, when I get a house,
I'm getting a grill and I'm getting
one of those goddamn Joe Rogan boxes.
That's what I call them.
Getting one of them Joe Rogan boxes
and I'm putting that shit in my fucking
man-cave. Everybody should
have an isolation tank. It's a,
it's a fucking beautiful
thing to have man. It just,
it settles your mind like
nothing else. Yeah. That's,
that's the thing that I always
struggle with is just too many.
I got too many tabs open, of course,
at all times. And so is comics too.
Yeah. And the only thing that slows me
down is video games and puzzles. Puzzles.
Yeah. My putting pictures,
jigsaw and Sudoku.
Ah, does it,
like those are the three things that I
can do that I know immediately the moment
I start the activity, everything closes
and I'm just focusing on one thing.
That's the only thing I can do when
I need to get my mind off of stuff.
I was dating this girl one
time and get on. You're not,
you're in the middle of an argument
and so you're trying not to,
you're trying not to be
a Dick in the moment.
So I just start doing the puzzle and just
trying to stay calm and then she walks
over and just starts undoing
the puzzle as I'm doing.
Oh my goodness. Oh fuck. Oh my
goodness. I'm doing, Oh, the anger
sign. That's a sign of
someone's intentions.
When someone's fun doing your puzzle,
like, Oh, you're one of those things.
This is my place. This is the one
place I can go and just be escalate.
Deescalate. Yeah.
Yeah. Well that's bad intentions. Yeah.
That's like seriously bad intentions.
Someone trying to undo your puzzle. Yeah.
That's some shitty kids will
fight to the death over that.
I'm gonna say the place
to start [inaudible] like
when we eat smokers say you
fucking up. They're high. Right,
I understand that now. Yeah,
that's, that's the one thing.
I'm not with her anymore. No, no, no,
no. I crashed that. You can't, I'll,
I'll take responsibility on that. We
got puzzles. That's my thing. Man.
Puzzles and a little bit of
video again and bad and cages.
I'd love to help Mark Ellison
and Craig. That would be amazing.
But you need a lot of space.
You need like Ellie yard? Yeah,
I'm in New York right now. There's
nowhere to put a few live in the city.
There's no way to fucking, do
you like living in the city? No.
Why are you there? Cause the
daily show, it's gonna work.
So that's where the fucking job is.
I take the train to Brooklyn. Yeah,
I thought about it at first, but then I
had a kid the same year I got the show,
so I needed to be closer.
So we got to Harlem.
So Harlem is at least the shorter
commute to the studio. How far?
Where's the studio studios on West
side Hills kitchen on the water.
So it's like 53rd 54th street and
we're liking the one thirties so no,
it's, yeah, it's closer
than Brooklyn. Right.
Which was where I was originally
when I first got to New York.
Did you take the subway from Brooklyn?
Like yay. I tried to be a city boy.
The problem is that I've gotten more done
career wise in New York and four years
and then I did the eight years I was in
LA probably because of the show. Yeah,
it's just New York. It's just more, I
just, there's more of a hustle mentality.
Really. Yeah, I think so.
I think that I'm more prone to run into
comics that are going, going, going,
going, going. And so when you're
around that it makes you want to,
Glenn makes you want to write,
cause you see so-and-so working on
a new bit and doing all of that.
And I didn't see as much of that in LA.
Now granted you don't get to do as many
sets in LA because of the logistics of
the city. But I just felt like
there was more of a go, go,
go mentality that just rubs off
on you more because of that.
You don't get to socialize. Uh,
all of my friends are in LA,
so a lot of social relationships have
suffered because New York is go, go,
go and you're trying to get
the next career thing done.
And then you also got to
go home and be a dad. Yeah.
That's gotta be weird raising kids
in LA or in New York too, rather. Um,
I talked to, um, Gaffigan about that.
He's raised all his kids in New York city.
Yeah. And they're in like Manhattan or
they're in Jersey. Where in Manhattan?
He's been in Manhattan
forever. Yeah, I don't,
I don't know if that's
something not for the long run.
How old your kid is three now.
So he's young enough so
that it will leave him.
Come on back out to LA Roy.
Either LA or I would go to Atlanta
or the last grade or some shit.
That's a good move. Nate BARR gas, he's
shown us the recipe. What's he live in?
Well, you know, he's, I know he's,
I think he's got a place down South in
Atlanta. No, in Nashville. Oh no shit.
Yeah. Listen, those are
both great cities. If you,
if you're traveling on the road all the
time and you just need a base, you know,
and look man, you live, I have a buddy
of mine lives outside of Nashville.
He fucking takes pictures of his yards.
It's all green. I hear birds chirping,
shit, you know. Yeah. You knew
rateable. You need yard man.
I grew up with a yard and you know, so
that, and then family and it's just,
it's a, I feel like New
York is a great place to go,
but it's not the best place to
start necessarily. Yeah. As a child.
But I mean like guys start in LA,
people can start anywhere. I mean,
it's better starting and it's better
start in there than like a place that
doesn't have much of a
scene. Like maybe Phoenix.
Phoenix has like a little bit of a scene.
Oh yeah. My first nine years were all
Southern. I was a road guy at Alabama.
I started in Tallahassee and
Birmingham where like those days I can,
98 open mic was once
a month per city. Wow.
So every week if you wanted to get on,
you had to get on the Greyhound
and go to another fucking city.
That's commitment. So that's the only
way. And then we started creating stages,
like in the panhandle life from
Fort Walton over to Jacksonville.
You started meeting? Yeah.
You form a little fucking network and
this guy's got a Monday night at a shit
hole.
This guy's got a Tuesday night at
another shit hole and looking back on it,
it was all trashed age time. That's
the best you could do until you move.
It is amazing though. How many guys
have crafted careers? Just doing that,
like the will, the will to do,
do time and defined spots and
to find place to work out.
I wouldn't make the argument that I'm
better off now as a comic 20 years in
having started on the road instead
of starting in a major market.
Just because I feel like when you're a
road guy you meet every version of what
your career could end up being when
you're young. Because if you're,
if you're San Fran, if
you're a big city comic,
you only hanging with your peers. You
run into the big wigs every now and then,
but at some high end Bible shit at the
comedy club and then they go on their
way.
But when you do a weekend with Ron white
and you get to watch him properly night
after night after night, that's a fucking
tutorial and that's a fucking gift.
And then you can do what weekend?
The very next weekend with a guy
who's been doing it 30 years,
hadn't written a new joke and 15
burnout, alcoholic hates his kids,
hates his wife.
And once I got to LA you
start seeing, well, no,
I know to avoid that because
I'll end up like that dude.
I know not to do that because I'll end
up like that. That was a comic, goddamn,
I can't name names. There
was a comic that used to,
he won custody of his child and the one
thing in the court order was that she
could not be around the comedy
club. So you know what he did if I,
William brought her around the
comedy club. So as this feature,
I watched his seven year old while
he would go out and do his set.
Oh Jesus. Yeah, but that,
that's the last that he was kid
because of that. I don't know.
I haven't seen him since. Fuck,
you can't bring your kids seven year olds.
I brought my kids when they were like a
nine and seven outside a comedy club and
I let them, I let them peek in. It was
at the improv in Irvine. And I said,
cause we were all down there having dinner
together. And I did my show. And uh,
they, they were like around
the corner. I said, come on,
let me take you backstage. I'll
show you what it's like. And I,
and the show was about to start
and I had my daughter like come on,
peak out peak out there. And she's like,
Oh my God, look at all those people.
I would say on stage, I was like, Oh
Ron stage. It's like, should I no,
don't run on stage. Come back.
And that's safe. That's safe.
But to have them listen
to your shit. Nope.
What that taught me was the importance
of how important it is who you end up
with as it relates to your career.
How's it can choke your career.
Cause a lot of the guys that I started
with, you know, a lot of road guys,
they're not doing it anymore or they're
doing it at the same level that they
were at 98 and a lot of them I can point
to dating the wrong person who attacked
their psyche and their self esteem
in that three, four year window.
Cause I feel like every year
you get another opportunity
to skip a level. Right?
Right. And if you don't skip that
level, you go back down to levels.
And so these guys are trying to go from
here to here and you're with someone
that's attack. Why are you doing
that? You shouldn't be doing that.
There was a guy that used to take me
on the road with him down South, um,
kind of want some mentorship type
shit. And we would go do gigs.
And if it was within
four hours of the city,
his wife would roll, his wife would roll.
And both kids are in the
back seat, car seat age.
It's like nine o'clock in Georgia and
we're just riding together to a fucking
gig.
We would do the show and then in exchange
for an opportunity for stage time,
I would drive this family back home and
then I would go home and sleep in my
bed. But we didn't spend the night.
The family would stay at the
hotel while we did the show,
and then we would get back in the
car and drive the fuck back home.
Knowing what I know now, he
was fucking chicks on the road.
Ah.
And the only way she was comfortable with
him still doing standup was if she got
the role. Interesting. And that's
gotta be stressful. He fucked up.
He fucked up. But he tried to have both.
He tried to say that both he tried to
save to career and tried to save the
marriage. Yeah.
And I think who you deal with outside
the business is as important as how you
handle yourself in the business.
I understand that her
position and that one,
I understand that her more than I
understand the lady who was undoing your
puzzle. I don't understand that.
I don't understand that mindset.
That's a different mindset. A woman,
Alicia solution. That makes sense. Yeah.
She's trying to figure out a
problem. Well the solutions problem.
You still want to do comedy or I'm
coming with you. That makes sense.
You shouldn't have a three year old
in a car seat for eight hours on no
Wednesday night. No, no, no. Just
cruising the freeway. Yeah. Oof.
But if that's the proposition she presents
to you in order for you to continue
doing your career, then you know, you
either got to take it or leave it.
Yeah. Comedy is a tricky one man,
because in order to do it correctly,
you have to do it almost all the
time. You gotta be up all the time.
I got a good situation where
my kids are in bed by like,
you know, eight o'clock on a week
night and that's when I leave.
Yeah.
I kiss them goodnight,
you know, and uh, I,
my spots in the store usually around
10, so, uh, I'll just roll in, you know,
I'll hang up my wife for a little
bit and then I'll drive into town.
It's perfect.
But when do you evil sense?
Cause that's where I start running into
overlap and time is figuring out the
execution of comedy versus
the preparation to do comedy.
Mm. So reviewing the set, watching
tapes, well a big one. Yeah.
A big one for me is the
drive there and home.
So it's 35 minutes to the
store, 35 minutes home.
So that's when I'm reviewing material.
I listen to recordings so they
have it Bluetooth on my phone.
So I do that through the speakers of the,
of the car and that helps a lot.
That helps a lot. That's gigantic.
You know, like uh, it
also puts me into mind.
I feel like the more sets you do,
right, the tidy your standup is,
but the more focus you put on your set,
like it's almost as good
as like a half a set.
Like listening to a full set
is like a doing a half a set.
That's how I think about it.
I feel like the same way you found all
the extra that you found all the fat to
trim. Yeah. You find the fat to trim and
you also find like a spark. Like, Oh,
why did I say that? Ooh, there
might be something there. And then,
and then you've got to
write that down. And then,
and then I spent time just going over
scribbles like right here, you know,
like straight pride parade, like a
little, okay. A little scribbles.
You know what I mean? Like, okay, what
was I thinking there? Oh, that's right,
that's right. It's right there.
And then I'll start adding stuff together
and then I spend time just straight
out writing the straight
out writing times.
Almost always when everyone's asleep.
So like when I come home from the store,
it's like midnight or something like
that that everyone has to pass time,
spark up a joint, fire up the old
fucking laptop. And that's when I ride.
There's, there's a time,
the thing that I struggled with
the most in writing is consumption.
Um,
Chappelle says something years ago in a
magazine about how every comedian needs
to understand how their joke machine
works and identifying the stimuli that you
were encountering during the time when
you are having a creative high in your,
in the writing cycle, when ideas
are just popping in, coming to you,
document what was happening,
what was going on during that time and
do your best to recreate those situations
and scenarios to inspire writing
when you have writer's block.
So I know for me it's stuff that
bores me or stuff that annoys me,
be it reading, magazines, TV, whatever.
So I have to find time to watch it that
I don't like or can't stand because I
know my mind will wander into a place
where I can write some stuff but like to
physically just sit and consume television
and that's what I have to start doing
on the go. Like I get it now. Like, I
used to think these people were stupid,
and now I'm one of those people who walks
around staring at the fucking phone,
watching my DVR on the train or something
because I have to constantly take in
so that when it is time to write that
there's something that there's something
writing there.
I had a conversation with Theo Von
about this last night where he, uh,
he's burnt out and he had a cancel
some shows and I said, what's going on?
And he said, man, he goes, I just been
going too hard, too hard, too much,
too many weekends, you know, nine shows
a week over and over and over again.
Seven, eight, nine, 10 weeks in a row.
He goes, I just, I need to stop. He goes,
I'm not taking anything in recovery.
He goes, everything I'm putting,
I'm just putting everything out. He goes,
I didn't know. I had nothing to say.
Everything seems fake when I'm saying
it. Like I feel, I've felt, you know,
that, you know,
you laugh when you felt that spot where
you feel like everything you're saying
feels fake. Like you're just bullshitting.
Yeah. I, I'm trying to,
I'm still working on a lot more stuff
that has more teeth to it and I'm starting
to become obsessed as in the word,
but there's something noodle in at me
about veterans and the trajectory of
veterans when they come back
from war and all of that shit.
And I was trying to work on a bit about
Vietnam and started watching this Ken
burns documentary that's on
Netflix right now. And it's like,
it's fucking crazy. Like they,
they interviewed North Vietnamese
soldiers as well. Like I ain't never,
ain't never in my life.
So you know shit like,
cause normally Vietnam is always told
from our POV and they're sitting down with
just straight out via Carla. Yeah. We
was trying to get them motherfuckers,
we'd set them up like an remorseful in
the sense of speaking about the war from
their perspective and going and,
and it tells the story from
both sides and so it changed,
it altered how I want to tell the joke.
And that's the stuff that you have to
do from time to time to make sure that
your jokes aren't weighted to
one to one side that's black,
but level material, man,
if you're gonna make some jokes about
war and Vietnam and soldiers and soldiers
returning, you're just, you're,
you're entering into the trickiest
of balancing beams. Right.
That's where the reward, that's that
Gabby Douglas, double, triple, whatever.
I'm sorry, some of them Biles. Pardon
me, Simone Biles, and yet she did,
what did she do? I don't know.
Something they'll make illegal and
competition next year because black women
did. And you're like, no, don't
do that shit no more bitch.
It's like when Syria Bonelli was figure
skating and she did a back flip on the
ice and they were like, yeah, no more.
Backflips they said, no more back. Yeah.
They were like, you know, yeah,
there's French chick did a back flip
and immediately the ILC was like,
no more backflips it was too amazing.
Wow. Maybe they're worried
about like those BMX dudes,
BMX dudes and they started doing double
flips and they started doing flip,
triple flips. A bunch of them started
crashing and breaking their necks.
Oh, that fucking snowboard
shit. That's insane.
Yeah. Snowboard freestyle.
You're stuck on that thing too. It's
not like skis where your legs move.
That one in the snowmobile where they're
coming over the handlebars of the
snowmobile and coming back
down. I'm like, no man, no
anything with BMX or
motocross or any of those crazy
white dudes that are doing flips.
It's all just how many flips can you do
landing on your front tire and the Rex
man, I spent an hour one
night just watching Rex,
just watching guys try to
do flips and land wrong.
It's like picturing nerves
getting ruined for life.
Spinal cord injury, compound fractures.
There's a birth of big air 30 for 30
where he'd talk about when he started this
shit in the 80s in Oklahoma and it
would just doing it for the love,
like there's just a dude with a ramp
in his yard and just work traveled.
No email, no nothing. Just word
of mouth does a dude with a ramp.
So when we're in town to do that race,
we're going to go over to this dude
yard do for that ward. Dangerous shit.
You gotta be like a trapeze guy.
Like before there was motorcross
and bikes and shit. What did you do?
Like if you are a crazy person,
you gotta be a trapeze guy. Yeah,
we'll real options. You have
winning with skateboarding.
Skateboarding wasn't really,
they weren't thrashing like
that in the 80s you know,
they were just rolling around like
assholes. Like we're on a sidewalk,
move it pedestrian. The crazy
shit they did is get in a pool.
We're in a bottom of a pool. This
is nuts man. We're on the edge.
The shit they do not like kids
like in general athletics wise,
like the stuff they're doing now. Like
you see it and in jujitsu and an MMA,
the kids that are coming up now, they're
though they're so advanced in there,
they're all doing flying triangles
and flying armbars on each other.
It's like God damn like humans are
evolving. So I came up playing baseball.
Is there, are there certain maneuver
like in baseball before you turn like 15,
I think they try to limit you
throwing breaking balls. Mm.
Cause it'll fuck with ya. Um, elbow
Tommy, John and all that shit. Right?
So are there MMA moves where
you just as a child, you just,
you're not allowed to do this yet. You
have to be your grown man leg locks.
As a beginner,
they generally try to get you to stay
the fuck away from leg locks cause leg
locks. I don't know if you're
familiar like heel hooks. There's,
there's techniques that you do that are
going against the edge of your knee.
So like, here's your knee, your
knee bends like this, right?
They're going against it this way, trying
to bend or back that way. And it just,
you're, there's not much
give in your knees, man.
And so when you get a heel
hook, it's like your leg,
your leg is like in front of like wrapped
around a guy and they've got their
heel trap like this and they're pulling
on your knees sideways and your knee
just gets ripped apart.
And it happens. It's very,
very common that guys get knee
injuries from being overzealous and uh,
not, not, not like giving a guy a
chance to get out of a technique.
There's a heel hook right there. I see
that guy screaming at his fucking face,
bro. I'm telling you it is
some fucking horrific pain.
You get your [inaudible] tear it
apart, your fucking ligaments pop.
You know, it's, it's a
terrible, terrible feeling.
And there's not much room for like in
an arm bar does like your arm is locked
out. You can kind of take it a
little bit before you have to tap.
But with your knee, the moment you feel
pain, it's too late. Your for, yeah,
look at that right there. Whoo.
Look how bad it is. Ripped apart.
That's Dean Lister, Dean Lister's up
fucking gorilla. That dude on the bottom.
He's like one of the leg
lock pioneers in jujitsu.
He's fucked up many dudes. Future
walking. I'll say this about MMA.
It's definitely leveled bar fights.
Oh yeah, a little bit more now.
I've seen some scrawny guys like really
fuck a big dude that know what they're
doing. Yeah.
Like at five and you'd just see the D
and it's funny because there's all the
shit talking before the fight
and then the fight starts.
And then of course the big dude is like
tapping and does the scrawny do to still
go on. I'm like, dude, there's
no riff. You're, you're at a bar.
Like this isn't, you don't get
to tap out. You get your shit
broken. Yeah. There's a lot
of people that get in fights,
don't know what they're doing.
It's strange. It's like,
imagine if you challenged
the guy to a basketball game.
You've never played basketball. We were
ridiculous. Like, I know how to do it.
I've watched it on TV, but there's a
lot of people that do that with fights,
but the consequences of a fight are way
more grave than the consequences of a
basketball game. Somebody
kicks your ass in basketball.
You just look like a fool. Somebody
kicks your ass in a fight. You're you,
you getting fucked up. Maybe permanently.
Maybe your face is gonna be scarred
up for life and ain't no fighter man.
I'm Oh one in one lifetime.
Oh one and one one draw.
What happened with the draw teacher show
and got in a fight and got in a
fight in the eighth grade at a stop.
The violence rally. No, that's real shit
cause I figured that'd be
the best place to talk. Shit.
What's, what's a better spot?
Talk your shit than at a stop the violence
rally because presumably someone will
come in and go, Hey man, right,
let's not do we brothers and our
Mario Brown slept the shit out of me.
Mario Brown. Where are you at Mario?
Mario Brown is uh, air force retired.
We'll still, we're cool. We'll pull
it to this day now. But on that day
he slipped. It dug shit out of me
in the gym in front of everybody.
That's the worst. And you take
your ill in front of everybody.
Ooh, that's a hard one.
That's a hard L thought I was going to
get off on that one wrong. You know,
I didn't know how to fight at
all until I learned how to fight.
I was terrified of fights
and never, never, never was.
Never was the guy who like,
I was just trying to get away from
everybody cause I grew up in different
places. We moved around
a lot when I was a kid,
so I didn't grow up like with a bunch of
friends where everybody knew everybody.
It's like I was always the new kid
so, so you always had to always,
always. And so then when I was 14,
I was like, all right, fuck this.
I moved to a new city, new town. And I
was like, I gotta learn how to fight.
And so I take, started taking martial
arts. I just became obsessed with it.
Do you teach your kids?
Yeah. Yeah. I teach them,
but they're not into it anymore. They
uh, they were into it for a little while,
but they, they like doing other
stuff. Mostly gymnastics and shit.
But do you, are you teaching
them, did you think to it?
Cause I'm trying to say it with my son.
You know how to approach
self-defense. How he's three,
he's three. I noticed that early. Yeah.
But it's not, it's,
it's not a bad thing to get it to be
a part of his body when he's really
[inaudible]
black daughter started when she was five.
But the question becomes about
teaching proper conflict resolution.
Cause I also,
I'm wired a little weird in the sense
that I feel like because he's a black kid,
he's not going to get judged the
same if he throws the first punch.
So I don't want them in a position where
he might get expelled or some shit,
you know? Right. But if you've
got to get him out the fuck off,
you gone on bend that knee
sideways. You got to guess.
Well that's the beautiful thing about
kids learning jujitsu too is that also the
really used to conflict because you
have conflict in the gym all the time.
Not conflict in a negative
way, but when you're sparring,
you know you slap hands and you
just do it and you go full blast.
You try to get each other as hard as
you can and you can do that in jujitsu
cause you're not hitting each other.
You just choking each other and getting
an arm bars and then when some gets you
you just tap and then you move
on to the next thing. And the,
the thing about doing that is then
you're not worried about conflict.
It doesn't seem as scary
to you. Like for me,
until I started learning martial arts,
I was fucking terrified of everybody.
I thought everybody was going to kick
my ass. Like fuck. I was like every,
I'd seen some do that bullied me and
like Schiff and I'd go around the whole
opposite way of school. I'd walk the
total way around the school to get to the
ah bro, how much longer was that?
15 extra minutes. I didn't care.
I have to walk 20 extra minutes home if
I didn't want to cut through the South
park projects cause there was this dude
Spencer that was always every week for
sure. Go on, give me the damn business.
Those people would ruin
your lives every week.
Like they would sit on the porch and
watch me walk in the corner store and then
would come and take my fucking now
ladies and laughing and mind you,
I've set aside lunch on my,
I ate less at lunch so I can eat candy
and chips on the way home and they were
snatched that shit right out. My only
thing you say me growing up, I had an ad,
a good ass basketball goal.
So all the gang bangers
in the neighborhood would
come to our yard to shoot
ball. So I essentially learned every,
every terrible person in my neighborhood,
shot ball at my house.
So you can't fuck with me because
then you won't be able to shoot ball.
Oh that's nice. So I don't know
if my mom did that by design.
I know she did it to keep me from going
up to Powderly park to shoot ball where,
you know, that's why the
bullshit would go down.
But all the bullshit came to her house.
But out of respect to my mom and my dad,
like they never started shit and I just
walk around the neighborhood perfectly
fine. Now at school I can
still get fucked with,
but on the walk home it was
gravy. That's very nice.
Once she got the basketball that was good.
That's very nice. Yeah, it's hard.
A kid who's really mean who's like
bullying you in high school and and junior
high school and that
could fuck whole lives up.
Sometimes people never recover
from that shit. You know,
it's a natural inclination that people
have to fuck with someone who's scared
and weak to just you see it in
animals man. You see in dog.
Yeah we are animals.
That's what we forget.
We get like clothes and automobiles
of civilizes. No it still,
I'm trying to take your woman
and reproduce and I'm trying to,
if I can spread my genes and
I'm going to take your food.
Like that's the basic of bullying is that
[inaudible] yeah, it's nature
and it forces you to overcome.
Cause almost every fighter that have
ever met professional fighter was fucked
with George Saint Pierre, who's like
one of the greatest of all time,
told the story on the podcast about,
he was a driving his range Rover when he
was world champion through Montreal and
he saw this homeless guy and the homeless
guy was his bully in high school and
he realized, he was like, Whoa.
And he's like, what's going on man?
What are you doing?
And like talk to the guy and try to make
amends with the guy and help him out a
little bit. But it's like fuck man,
this is his bully in high school.
And he realized like most people that
are causing pain and inflicting pain on
people, they're in pain, man. That's
why they're doing it. You know,
it's like victims,
you know the victims of crimes often
times perpetrate those crimes on other
people that that happens. Kids get
abused at home, they get beaten at home.
They're the ones who want to beaten kids
up at school. You know, they're just,
they want to dish out that violence on
someone smaller than them cause they're
getting a dished out on them by someone's
larger. Yeah, man. I mean that's,
that's the constant victim
narrative. But on the other hand,
families of people that grow up
that are martial artists, like,
like all the kids know how to fight.
They're the nicest, friendliest people.
They don't worry about it. It's not
the thing that fucks with their head.
Like for me, I knew I didn't know
how to fight. So it was scary.
So like every time someone would fuck
with me, I'd be like, Oh, got to get away.
I can't fight. I don't
know what I'm doing.
Some dude got me in a headlock and threw
me down on the ground and was gonna
punch me in the face. I'll never forget
this. Like, I forget what was happening.
We were talk. We, like I said something,
he said something stupid to me.
I said something stupid back to him.
Then he just got me in a headlock and
threw me on the ground and he helped me
like that. He was gonna punch you. I
was like, nah man, I ain't gonna bother.
I'm just sitting there going
God damn, I'm helpless.
Locked up in a headlock with this
dude on top of me going fuck.
And the only is the only his mercy that
he didn't punch my fucking face in or he
didn't want to get suspended or
whatever and I remember going that's it.
I'm going to learn how to
fight. This is ridiculous.
Do you,
do you ever run into the people from your
past who have a revision as history on
y'alls relationship and they
not too much cause the only people that
I'm friends with from back then I'm
actually good friends with and I was
friends with when I was growing up like a
couple of buddies. But
most people I don't,
well most of the dates they never bought
a ticket to your show and came up to
them?
No, by the time about a time
I was in high school that's,
that's the only people that are
still I am in contact with anymore.
I had already gotten balls deep in
martial arts like my first year of high
school. So by like into high
school, I was already crazy.
I was already competing and traveling
all over the place and so it was,
but I do run into people
that fake stories.
I run into people that
tell me things that hat,
remember that time we were at a party,
you kicked out dude in the hand.
I'm like, dude, I never kicked
anybody. Never happened.
The dead a hundred percent
definitely never happened.
I never went to a party
and beat anybody's ass.
Never have him with that memory
or do you correct them? Correct.
Dumb. I'm like, I never fought anybody.
Some dude was telling me some story
about some guy told him that one time we
were on the street and some guys
across the street were talking shit.
And I went across the street and kicked
both of them in the head and like that
never happened. Never happened. I'm
a guarantee you it never happened.
Cause the last time I was in a street
fight, I was like 15 I'm like this,
it never happened. This is not a true
story. See, I'm the opposite man.
People come to me with shit that I
don't remember. I just let them have it.
If that's your memory of us in
college, fine. Whatever. Weird though.
Right? When you know
when you definitely know.
Like I know for a fact,
I was never in any street
fights outside of high school.
I had a professor from
college accused me in a fake,
this was a Facebook thread of some
article about me and like all the other
alumni commenting on it.
And one of the professors I remember in
1994 when you said this thing to me in
class and stormed out of class, I'm like,
I didn't enroll until 96 but
I didn't say that. I just,
I literally just apologize like,
because she's clearly been mad at me
all of this time about something that I
didn't even do. And I'm just like,
there's nothing I can say this.
That's your narrative.
Fine. You know what?
I'm sorry for the shit that I didn't
do. Whatever. Roy would all peaceful.
But yeah. But then she replies on her
that, well, thank you. It means a lot.
And then so in my weird arrogant brain,
I've freed her
of her anger or whatever the fuck it is.
She thought I did, but I didn't do it.
That's a great approach. I just
don't feel like going back and forth.
That's a great approach.
It's so much easier to evade.
I'm more of an Aveda and
a schemer than a fighter.
I'm not gonna argue with
you and go back and forth,
but what I will try and figure out a
way to do is over the next two years,
diabolically dismantling anything
you stand for and believe in.
Like that's, that's my approach to things.
Like there's a comedy club owner.
God is my witness before I die,
I'm opening a comedy club across
the street. This is a NIGO. No,
I've heard the stories.
Where's this one? Uh,
can you not tell? It's easy.
It's one of the Carolinas.
Well, we'll, you know,
[inaudible] the internet.
We have such a complicated relationship
with them because we need them and we
don't want to do it. I don't want to
fucking run a goddamn comedy club,
but we need one. You know,
to have some guys dealing with a bunch
of maniacs like us, day in, day out,
every week coming in and telling jokes
and getting drunk smoking weed in the
green room and all the chaos that comes
to the art form. Yeah. We need this
to the comedy club as essential.
100% you ever get scared that the young
people don't really go to the clubs?
Don't really fuck with
clubs. Yes, yes I do.
It's going to change the business
model like in the next decade.
Well,
one of the beautiful things about comedy
clubs though is that we all use them.
Like even if you're doing arenas,
like you use comedy clubs,
you use comedy clubs to exercise.
Like Chappelle comes in all the time.
Does the belly room, that's a 70 seat
room that dude just strolls on in.
It'd be half-full. Yep. And
he'll do 40 fucking minutes.
And that is so critical, man. It's so,
it's so important to get that work in.
That's why I don't like when
a lot of the vets attack the,
as they call them Instagram comedians
or the vine or not vine anymore,
but [inaudible] what the fuck? Yeah,
they get mad at them because the
club will book them and they'll go,
well the live shit was
trash and it's terrible.
And it's true for most of them it's
not the greatest performance cause they
haven't had the chop shit,
but they sold 300 paid tickets
and everybody ate and drank.
What do you think is keeping the lights
on for your 30% selling capacity as
to come
back in next year and then next year
to go from 30% sold to 40% sold.
They're not making no money off of you,
but if these IgE comedians can come in
and at least help keep the lights on,
I think in the greater
integrator scheme of comedy,
there's more good than bad that comes
from that. And I also feel like there's,
there's a,
there's a level of ignoring the tools
that they've been able to use to get an
audience in lieu of the fact that they
don't put new standup on TV anymore and
lets it's contest shit. Comedy
central just started with the,
the lab at the cellar shit. But other
than that, I mean it hasn't been a lot.
Well no one's even watching
TV anymore. I mean,
the numbers on regular TV
programs are so low now.
Like if you're doing a set on Conan,
like what is, what did we win over this?
Right. Like the numbers are like less
than 400,000 people watch it a night.
Yeah. That's a lot. That might be
live plus three yeah. On top of that,
I might not even be just live. They might
be live plus DVR over the [inaudible].
Yeah. It's crazy. So no one's
watching anything anymore.
If you can get onto a stage,
the way I feel about Instagram comedians
or YouTube comedians is if you're doing
standup, you're a comic.
You might be a shitty comic and you
might've be a famous shitty comic because
you're famous from vine or
whatever the fuck it is,
but who's your comic like it's whether
or not you decide to become a real comic
and actually do the work and put in
the time and then one day be, look,
I hope that we see these YouTube comics
and they're fucking terrible and then
you go to see them seven,
eight years later and they're
murdering their crushing. Great timing,
great premises. I'm like, we got
one, we got one. We need more.
This is a hard gig. Think about what
you had to do when you were starting.
Think about you traveling
around, all those fucking things.
Getting on a bus to do open mics.
They had an open Mike once a month.
That takes a kind of grit and
resolve that. Most people don't.
This shit is like hazing
where the O heads feel like,
well they didn't suffer the way I suffer.
Therefore your success is invalid.
I don't take that cause you
didn't do it the way I did it.
This is the only way to do it. The
game evolves that the points of access,
it's like, it's like comedy is like,
to me it's like a fucking grocery
store and you've been in line,
you've been in this checkout line and
then a new checkout line opens and then
all these fuckers just cruise through
that checkout and you're still stuck in
the same waiting to get a tonight show
set line and the Instagram line opens and
people just start whisking through to
success and you don't know whether or not
to change lines or stay in this one.
You build.
The beautiful thing about comedy is
you don't have to get out of the line.
He just opened up a new line, open up an
Instagram line, open up a YouTube line.
You can do all those,
but they ain't been waiting
in line as long as me.
So why did they get to leave the
store? You know you have that jealousy,
that little piece of jealousy
when someone has not been in line.
As long as you leave the grocery
store before you, that's comedy now.
It is, but it's wasted energy. You
can't think about that. You can't, like,
you should think about that the same way
you think about someone having success
in some field that has
nothing to do with yours.
Like if someone who is a Nobel
prize winning scientists like fuck,
I could have done that, but you didn't.
It's really the same thing. It's just,
yeah, it has nothing to do.
But some people are like that.
Some people see someone
with like a startup,
some internet startup and it makes
$1 billion and they get angry.
They get angry because no,
go, go fucking do something.
Don't worry about what
other people are doing.
It's a giant waste of your energy.
Yo, I read a book, um,
rebel without a crew.
Think it's um, I think rich Rodriguez,
I think his thing is his name.
And he was a film maker and he made the,
I can't remember the name of the movie,
but it was the prequel to what became
Desperado. Oh, rather target Rodriguez.
Yes. Yeah.
And you talked about just shooting that
shit gorilla and for essentially pennies
less than $10,000 shot a whole last
film and walks through how we cut the
corners and you think of how to shot
paranormal activity for like $55,000 50 or
$60,000. The first paranormal activity
was dirt cheap. They shot the first saw
$4 million in 30 days
in one building. Whoa.
Every and every scene in the car did
just shaken the fucking camera and jump
cutting billion dollar franchise
getting rebooted now like that.
Like when I see shit like that, I
don't get jealous. I go, well fuck.
I need to go and fucking gorilla
some shit together and learn.
So that's why I started trying
to learn like in video editing,
audio editing and all that shit, man.
Yeah, no, it was inspiring. I love one,
when I walked in the green when I
saw you fucking with that software.
I love when people are
hustling when they're doing
things like that. New things.
And you're like, you know what?
Fuck this final cut pro shit.
I'm going to learn Adobe premier.
They keep fucking with me.
Make me buy a new version
every year. [inaudible]
yup. Now to be fair, Adobe
makes you rent the shit,
but I think there's a way to, yeah,
does that too now with like Whoa,
office whole office suite $80 a year.
There's so many credit access
to it. Just crux, crux.
And then you can't use the old
version of office with the new,
and if I send you a file
that's like office Oh three,
you can't open it with the new off
like opens as a text file with no form.
Like they do it to fuck you
barely use office. I use it, I have it,
but I write with right room for the
most part. Do you know what that is?
Is that script software? It's no, it's um,
it's a software that turns your whole
screen black and then turns the text green
and you can't access your
browser. You can't do nothing.
You just have green software. Have you
ever seen it? No. You write down, Oh,
ms dos coding type action. Yeah.
On, uh, on my windows computer,
I use a [inaudible]. I use
a program called Scrivener.
I do most of my writing on that and
there is a distraction free option there.
That's what it looks like. That's
what it looks like. Matrix. Yes.
I write like I'm in the matrix.
That's how I write when I'm on my,
my Mac because I think they have
a version of that that they don't.
They have a version of that
for windows. I think they do,
but I've never really installed
it. I just use a, yeah, I need to,
yeah. It just says Macco S it
doesn't say anything about windows.
I heard a story that they wrote the first
independence day movie in three days
in a hotel room. Make sense?
So let's do it. Just focusing
in like that type of shit,
which has helped me focus.
You got a lot of coffee or some
Adderall or something like that.
You dumb action movie. Three days easy.
You can go crazy now. This is
a gorilla style shit man is.
That's how this podcast
gets started. This park,
this podcast reaches some
stupendous number of people
every month and it started
out with a laptop in my
living room cause I was bored.
Me and my friend Brian because uh, I had
just gotten back from Colorado and I'm,
I was like, yeah, I can't believe I'm
back in LA. This is fucking terrible.
I'm like, wow, let me do something.
And so I just started doing like Q and
A's on the like a like a laptop talking
to people on Ustream. Yeah.
That's the one thing I
wish I could have back.
I wish I had taken YouTube more seriously.
You take it right now though? I do now,
but not in 2005 when it
first came out to content.
Just start rolling out the same thing
you were complaining about before. No,
I'm just, it's the wish that I had done
something. That's what your career is,
is that man, if I hadn't done
this sooner and done two things,
I would've done sooner.
I'd taken the internet more seriously and
I would have taken some more as advice
and not gotten on TV for 10
years. I don't think any,
I don't think any comic can do it though.
I think it is impossible to be a working
comic and stay off of if you stayed off
of television for 10,
if you started your career and
just never did shit, no festivals,
just crush, crush, crush, crush.
You become fucking legend that
by the time you finally decide,
you look at college quarterback that
just stays in college for years and years
and years and never interested
the draft. And by the time you do,
then everything is stratosphere. But
there's too much money is too many offers.
Well, you know who did that? Joey D is,
Joey Diaz didn't do any standup
comedy on TV until like 1520 years in
[inaudible]. He was crushing. But Joey
also I think is from a different cloth.
We are, he wasn't seeking that out either.
He was, well, he was seeking it out.
They were scared of him. You know,
he was talking about eating ass and taking
in the muffler and all this chaos and
going to the Buffalo tick.
Yeah. He talks crazy.
But I think I have a different
perspective. I think, um, there's a,
I have a bunch of old sets for me.
When I was living, uh, I was on TV,
I was doing comedy like five years,
four years. They're terrible. Yeah.
But the good thing about it is they
exist and it's lets you see like,
look, this was in the beginning I was
talking terrible. But just keep going.
You just keep working at it, keep
working on it. You get better. You know,
like I'm not under any illusion
that I didn't use to suck.
I tried to talk about
it as much as possible.
I was terrible when I first started it.
You're okay with that being out there.
Don't give a fuck
dude. I've been digging in the crates.
I've been digitizing a lot of my
old VHS shit trying to, you know,
just for posterity and going
through some of my old fucking TVs.
They're all terrible. Like the Letterman
set is probably the only thing.
The Letterman and Def jam said and Oh
six those are the only two that I'd still
to this day, I still
stamp the sat, those jobs,
everything before that
premium blend star search.
Last comic standing Apollo
comic view, all of it.
I'm like, Barry, that shit. My
biggest fear is becoming famous.
Whatever the fuck that is. And then
B T just rolling out some sort of,
remember when fucking thread. Oh,
just you load of black comics. They used
to suck 20 years ago and just going,
no,
but that's who you were. That's, that's
part of the process. Yeah. I liked,
I liked the process. I don't
care. I'm fine with it.
The problem is that the
gatekeepers that decide stuff,
they only want the newest shiny
thing. So if they see you too soon,
you're new to rescue problem
Roy. That's the only problem.
You don't need those fucks. You
don't need gatekeepers. Internet.
The internet has no gatekeepers.
You have people that have podcasts
that get you on their podcasts.
You do your own podcast, you would put
out a lot of content. No gatekeepers.
I'm with is that,
it takes comics discovering it because
the problem is a young comic is that you
inherit the goals of your
predecessors. So as a young comic,
especially as a road comment, every
road comic is trying to get on TV.
So they make you believe TV
is where you need to be going.
Don't fuck up the YouTube shit.
Little n***a tell you right now,
you got to get on, goddamn, let them,
and you get on Letterman and then you
get to show I got on Letterman and is not
a knock on Letterman and
it's worth as it credit,
but the worth of the late night credit
in 2006 versus 1996 it's not the same
currency. No, there was a deflation in
the currency, so it got me more rooms.
It got me more money,
but there was no Ray Romano
fucking here's your career,
choose your career, here's your Kevin J
like, yeah, it doesn't work like that,
but the only,
but you're chasing what somebody else
wanted and the game is always moving.
The school of fish are always,
so you have to be ahead of that curve
and it's just didn't listen to the
instincts. Yeah. It's hard to
see where it's going though.
If the people from your
PR, your predecessors,
the the guys who were successful and
you were coming up where they were
headlining and you were middling
for them, that that was the goal.
The goal was the tonight
show. The goal was yet,
but I don't think is that
hard to see the future.
Not necessarily see the future,
but see the trends of where people,
what people are paying attention to.
I'm quicker to read fast company than
I am a variety or Hollywood reporter
because we're tech goes, that's
where people going. But people go,
they want to laugh.
So you figure out a way with that to
integrate laughter into whatever the new
tech or the new hat, like this
tick-tock, shit, whatever this, this,
that that is, I've seen it
but I don't know what it is.
A better fucking figure it out. Cause
that's the next one. Is it then?
That's the one you brought
up to you. We should,
maybe we should do a ticktock
account. I don't know
that you'll like it. It's music.
It's musical vine in a way.
Like it's, it's music sketches, but
it's still funny. It's entertaining.
So Thompson girl does it like all
the time he's into it. That's okay.
He's like ironically doing it. But
yeah, but he does some fun shit.
He does some funny shit.
It's self aware that he's a guy
that shouldn't be on tick-tock.
So his existence on tick tock is
what makes it funny and makes it,
he knows how to do that shit,
but he's ahead of me. He's a hit.
He's ahead of that curve.
So the other thing that then compounded
gas like me from my generation is that
Dane cook was one of the first
that was like, all right, fuck TV,
what's over here? And so
many people shitted on Dane.
Out of jealousy that you ignored the
fact that his mass space move was some
fucking Bosch shit. It was. It was
huge. It was huge for everybody.
I remember I read people magazine,
there was an article about how he had
like 200,000 or 300,000 MySpace friends.
That's crazy. I remember
thinking that is crazy.
How does he have so many friends? Yeah.
But he was using that and
talking to people online
constantly and rather look at
him and see how he did it. You stand
in your checkout lane and go fuck him.
He got out of the store
before me. Um, well I,
I shifted and I started
promoting on it. I didn't,
I'm just saying a lot of comics like me
just didn't you lean on what you're told
because you look at older
comics as mentors instead
of realizing that maybe they
don't have this shit figured out
either and you should be trusting your
instincts. He was the first guy, right?
He was the first to really make it
through the internet on the digital side.
Yeah, 100% yeah, I'd say that.
I can't think of anybody performed cause
I can't think of anything before that
other than Yahoo chat rooms.
No, he was the first guy.
He was the first guy on
the first guy for sure.
That became famous from my space.
My space was like the first platform
of that social network and shit.
His album sold like 2 million copies
or something crazy like retaliation.
Oh my God.
That's why if you stop and think about
how nuts that is today, like today,
a big artists like if M and M puts
out an album, how many does he sell?
I'd say 401st week. Maybe
three to 401st. Well,
let's give it a year. Depending on
what week you release right now,
you could be number one
with like 30 [inaudible]
thousand sales. Whoa.
Yeah. 40 50,000 sales boy.
They just gutted that record
business, didn't they? That is crazy.
What happened with the internet?
The internet took out porn and
took out music by the knees.
I used to have a fucking neighbor.
He lived right down the street
like two houses down from me.
This crazy porn dude. I used
to do jujitsu with them too.
It's all steroid up and maniac wild
eyes too. It was just crazy. Just Coke.
Yes, Coke and steroids and he
was just fucking up a storm.
Constantly pulling.
It was like past his house and he's always
had these fat Mercedes parked in his
driveway and [inaudible] hot girls
in their underwear walking around was
hilarious. Let's do as
a maniac. But then they,
the internet came around the
internet just gutted his business,
just gut it and they repossessed
his house. I'll never forget man,
his fucking house got repossessed
and I remember seeing it in the,
like the real estate section. I was like,
fuck man, dude lost his house. He was,
he had a fat fucking Rolex
with diamonds all over it.
Pouring got really fucked over.
But you and you want to talk about the
people selecting what they want to see.
That's what's,
what's a bigger focus group than people
who want to fucking Jack off and they've
decided I would rather see somebody in
the hood in their house with no lighting
and just terrible fucking camera work.
And that's as interesting what it was.
It is that porn became free and they
just used ad clicks and they would just
pirate everyone's porn.
Say if you were a porn producer and
you were making a bunch of porn,
they would just take your point and put
it on like whatever website and then you
would have to get a lawyer
to try to take it down. Yeah,
it was like some lime
wire to the 80th pallor.
It was like way worse
than the entire business.
But you don't think the free side
or like the amateur porn? Oh yes.
Part of it too. I mean that's a
bigger now, but in the beginning, yes,
it was just pouring clips,
getting shopped up and nobody
paying a $40 for a five hour DVD.
You know what I notice? Not that
know. I was doing research recently.
You know what I noticed? There's
a lot of like stepmother porn.
It's a lot of like a step mom,
horny step-mom porn or
step-sister [inaudible].
It's all like taboo stuff. It's all was
also a lot of getting caught porn. Yes,
yes, yes, yes. Yeah.
Like the, the wife walks
in, you're in the middle of get your Dick.
Yeah. And it cuts right there
when she walks in. Yeah. Yeah.
There's a lot of that. I did a,
we did a story on racism
in porn for daily show.
And so we were shooting up in
Chatsworth for whatever. And what I did,
and I learned so much about the porn
industry in that I didn't know that,
like they would just have a fuck house
where it's like an eight bedroom house
and every bedroom is,
it's individual studio set up
for whatever genre of porn.
It was like at least five different
genres of porn being shot in that house.
And we're out in the,
and, and I, and mind you,
I still have this image that if you're
a porn star and you're working with a
porn studio, there's some Brit,
there's got to be little bit of money.
And one of the, um, porn
stars was, is it actress?
What's the fucking word now? Porn
actress. Yeah. So one of the actresses,
her car is blocking someone. So
I'd go out, just give me a keys,
I'll move your car in this car.
I had to be the most at the sad is
fucking like to the point where I'm like,
if this is what fucking
on camera gets you,
there's gotta be something else out there
and you want to talk about people that
need to see where the curve is.
I think if you're a woman and
you're cool but doing porn,
you're probably better off just doing
it on some self-starting shit than even
dealing with any of these LA
crooks in the first place.
Yeah. If you could figure
out a way to get an audience,
I know there's a lot
of dudes who, uh, they,
they run these companies that
girls use where they just, uh,
people pay to see their videos. Like,
like someone will ask you like, uh,
like if you're a, a porn
actress, they'll say, Hey,
I want you to use this dildo and cover
your tits whip cream and I'll give you
150 bucks. And then,
Oh, some live stream
private Skype protection.
Yeah.
They make their money doing that and
they'll do that like all day long and rake
in thousands of dollars.
Yeah.
Just like the food videos where you sit
but neck and eat some food and you go on
like a virtual date with the person. Yeah,
I think its butt naked foodie
sometimes naked. Sometimes not.
And like you haven't seen a
lot of that in Asia. Yeah.
A woman's just looking straight
at the camera. So anyway,
today I remember I'm young, I'm talked
to her. That's up to you. Back to her.
It's sometimes it's just a straight video
and you don't get to interact with it
because there's multiple people watching
the feet concurrently or if you want to
pay a little extra. Yeah. One-on-one.
I will sit here and pretend to be
on a date with you and we can just,
and it's just,
that's more feeding loneliness
and some sort of erotic desire,
but there's not a lot of money in it.
No Khalifa was talking about
this shit a couple of weeks ago.
What was she doing? She says she
only got like 12 K for the year.
She only did porn for like
a week, right? Didn't,
she deals like a year or something
like that, but whatever it was,
it should've been more than 12
K so let's all she deserves.
What I'm saying is I
didn't see the points.
I don't know whether or not it
should have been 12 ketchup.
She put in a solid effort. Less kidding.
If you're someone that wants to do porn,
you are coming off better
just setting up your webcam.
Like Joe Rogan day one podcast,
you and Brian would have a laptop and a
microphone and just turn into a web cam
on and just doing whatever the
fuck you want to do with yourself.
Then dealing with the industry and the
record industry is becoming similar to
that too.
I think so too.
But I think that it's hard for
them to find an audience that way.
There's so much porn.
Like I got a joke I was doing for awhile
about why are they making new porn?
Like who is jerked off to all of it. Yeah.
There's no way anyone has seen it all,
but yet they keep making new porn.
It's like, it's crazy. Like
there no demand. Like there's,
there's no demand for new
stuff. There's plenty.
Like you would have to be some
kind of crazy creep to the scene.
Every porn that I've ever is ever
existed, but it's no different than MMA.
This people innovate,
people innovate and in porn back
flipping and POV in the same areas,
breaking their necks. Yeah.
It's the, I think the,
the cam thing is the big thing. Girls
fuck on camera. You know, they'll,
they'll have the boyfriend come over and
they'll fuck them and suck his Dick on
camera and you pay to watch. And I
think that's, that's the big thing.
And they do private shows and
like the guy could tell, you know,
you could tell the girl, Hey,
I want you to do this to him.
And they'll do it on
camera. You notice training.
You know the funniest shit though.
So Steve burn and I, um,
we were in Pittsburgh and three things
lead to another and we ended up at a
strip club and it's a weekend.
And so apparently I didn't know this,
but porn stars tour strip clubs and
they'll go to a strip club on the weekend
and dance and sale,
whatever pocket pussy or whatever vagina
mole they have and all of the strippers
fucking, you know
like some of the shippers a cool cause.
Oh they bring more people into the club.
But for the most part the man are saving
that tip money to tip the porn star
that they came to see.
So it's like being a seasoned comic
and then the Instagram comment comes in
who's never stripped before.
Like yeah you fuck on camera but it's
not stripping what I do as an art.
What you do is slightly behaved cause
you not like there's like a beef between
like strippers and prostitutes.
Cause like some strip is a second fucking
in the back of the club and it fucks
up money for the rest of
the strippers that are,
that are playing the
game straight up. Right.
So it was this weird tension
in the strip club bow.
The porn star was on stage
and I could not stop laughing
because it was comedy.
And that's part of why like
stripping to me is performative.
It's in a weird way, it's comedy
and strip and it's damaged people,
entertaining strangers. So
there's more of a synergy.
So I don't really get anything out of
watching the stripper cause in the back of
my head, I know you're thinking
about groceries and some other shit,
but it was hilarious as a
comic to watch two different,
same different types of before.
It's like the magician versus the standup
versus the juggler and how they all
kind of don't really like one another for
one reason or another because they all
think what they do is superlative
to the other gas craft.
And it was, it was God damn
it was fucking hell there.
That is an inside scene that
only strippers can really
appreciate what you're
talking about. You know what I mean?
Yeah. Like for them, they're like, yes,
those bitches real than it coming
over here. Bunch of fucking whores.
There's, um,
there's a couple of strip clubs that I
used to go to and Birmingham where like,
you know, the club would close it
too and the police would leave.
And then at three the club,
it reopened and then it was open
season and is whatever you want to do.
And then you would see strippers in
the parking lot yelling at the other
strippers who were choosing to stay for
the 3:00 AM session saying that y'all
are messing it up.
And that's why nobody comes before
two is because of what you're doing.
And so it's just a,
so at three it became like a brothel.
Yeah. Wow. Yeah. That's insane.
Isn't it hilarious that you could fuck
anybody you want for free and there's not
a law about it. But as soon
as money gets exchanged,
you're a criminal and everybody's mad
at you. If you're just a slut, no one.
But if you want to fuck people from money,
that becomes a real problem for people
because people desire sex so much and
there's so many guys
that can not get laid,
but they've got some money and if
they find out they can pay for it,
like people are like, no, you
can't. You can't pay for it.
You could pay for everything.
Everything that's legal.
Everything else that's legal
you could pay for except sex.
You could pay to have
someone cook for you.
someone rub your back.
You could pay to have
someone cut your hair.
someone mow your lawn.
You could pay to have
someone take out your trash.
You could pay to have someone clean your
house. All things you don't want to do.
You can't pay for someone
to suck your Dick.
You can't that someone could do
it for free. If they like you,
there's no problems.
It's very strange or an
exchange for college tuition.
You can't even do that
if you made like a deal,
like you suck my Dick and I'll
give you a house. People go, Hey,
you can't do that. That's prostitution.
Very strange, right? I mean,
think about all the things we
do that we don't want to do,
but we do it for money. Everything's
fine. There's no issue. Even think like,
you know, I grew up doing
terrible construction jobs.
I'd never wanna do you know,
it might be better suck dudes did for
1000 bucks then don't look Lee drywall
fucking carry cement bags all
day for $400 for a whole week.
At least she got that.
I used to work day jobs.
I used to work day labor when I was on
the road as an MC so I can make more
money like in the one advantage to South
hat was that the comedy clubs back then
were like five, six day runs.
So during the day Columbia runs,
um, comedy house theater in Columbia.
South Carolina used to be a six night
room and it was Tuesday through Sunday.
So I would get to town Monday and
Tuesday morning I would go to a day labor
spot, get a job assignment
and work the whole week,
nine to five and then at night
go do my little MC bullshit.
Kids need to hear this kid's
coming out. They need to hear this.
That's important. You got it.
That's real hustling, dude,
why am I going to sit here in a hotel
all day and do nothing when I could go
make a quick like in minimum wage was
like five and a quarter. It's like you,
you're only making 40 bucks.
But that was extra money.
Like I counted on that little extra
money and we used to work summit fucking,
Oh my God. There's a quick Creek
factory in Columbia, South Carolina,
and I've worked there. I worked
there two weeks at a time.
Anytime I played the comedy club, I
worked at the quick Creek factory. Wow.
So did you have to call them up
or did you, how do you show up?
You show up at six in
the morning with your,
with your drivers license and you sign
up and then you sit in a lobby and you
watch the morning news until your name
is called and then they give you your job
assignment. Wow. And so you bring boots,
you bring a hard hat cause you
don't know what you're going to get.
You might get something with a keyboard,
you might just be outside holding the
stop slow fucking stop stick while they
pave a road. And that's your
gig for eight hours. Wow.
You just stand in the fucking Carolina
heat and just fucking five 25 an hour.
I love stories like this dude,
that was my first 10 years was just
working day labor weird jobs to make extra
money. Um, and if it, if the gig was
under five hours, I would drive back home.
Like I wouldn't even
stay so that I could go,
at the time I was still working morning
radio. So if it was within five hours,
I would do morning radio,
get off the air at 10,
be on the road by 11 five
hours nap. Do the show,
get back in my car at 10:00 PM
five hours back to Birmingham,
sleep at the station, wake up
at six wash, rinse, repeat. Or
I can't lose the radio
gig because that's too,
that was too much of a good get right.
And I was doing prank calls and
I was using the prank calls.
I was taking my prank calls at the time
and sending them to other morning shows.
This is website radio online,
which kind of breaks down.
It's almost like billboard, it's all,
it's almost like Nielsen or some shit,
but for radio.
And so I would go there and I would
look for other local morning shows that
weren't syndicated in cities
where I wasn't performing.
And so I would send my print calls for
free to these morning shows and go, look,
I'm a comic. Here's some free
print calls we do in Birmingham.
They're not going anywhere else. You
want to M an Omaha? The guy says,
yes, he's not. He doesn't have
shit else to play on the air.
So I was in the prank calls,
the guy that played a prank calls for
a couple of weeks, a couple months,
and then I would call the
local comedy club and go, Hey,
I want to feature in your room.
I'm on the radio and I know
I can get on there and had,
and this is when the belief that that
radio still could bring people to the
show.
So I would call local comedy clubs in
cities where my print calls with Aaron and
use that as leverage to get booked
as a feature instead of a MC.
And so that's how I was able to kind
of jump a level because I was a feature
that was coming in town with the pre
plugged in media access and all of that
shit.
Dude, you're a hustler, you're a real
hustler. I love hearing shit like that.
I really do. I love
hearing the driving part.
I love hearing that getting the day
job part. Kids need to hear this.
All you fucking kids listening to this
right now to think if you wanted a job in
show business, this is what comes with
it. And that's why you're so good, man.
That that hustler mentality, that's
so important. That's so important.
You just network,
you find people that you can that are as
driven as you and then you just figured
out ways to work together and
do shit. But comedy is so,
so many motherfuckers are lying
bro. They're lying. How so?
And you lie, you get the
leverage and like it's
like, so the way I got hired on radio,
so at the time the thought was that this
is 2001 I'm out of college and if I can
get on the radio then that'll give me
more access in the city and I can host my
own comedy night by hosting
my own comedy night.
I can offer money to out of towners who
also have comedy nights and do swap out.
So I needed to get the, the radio gig.
So at the time they were doing some sort
of contest or some shit and who's the
funniest in Birmingham or some shit.
And I missed the window for the contest.
And so I knew the long story.
Long story short is that I go to the radio
station. I asked the guy at the time,
buck, while whose house a
95, seven not the same storm.
Lot of different Buffalo,
any buck Wild's okay, perfect.
Say Oh different Buckwild. Okay.
So I said, Hey man, I'm a comic.
I have a degree in journalism.
It's a perfect fit. Fuck with me. And
he goes, nah, we're done with that.
We're not going to have a
comic. I go, okay, cool.
Now I've done enough of the comedy club
and Birmingham to know that on black
weekends,
the black radio station hosts the black
comedy night on Fridays and they throw
out tee shirts and all that shit.
So I'd go to the comedy club and
I told Bruce air, as I said, Hey,
I just got hired at 95, seven. Um,
and they want me to open for doc
ugly this weekend. And he goes, okay,
that's fine. I'll go back
to 95, seven. I go, yo,
I know you don't want to fuck with me,
but I'm opening for Dio this weekend.
Do me a favor, watch my set if I'm
funny. Put me on Monday morning. He goes,
you gotta deal.
So I get to the comedy club that Friday
and all I have to do is keep buck wound
Bruce heirs apart.
Okay,
so that neither one knows what the fucking
lie was and Bruce came backstage and
you just,
if as long as you act like you belong
and you act like the truth is the truth,
people will kind of merge in with that
shit and Bruce gamer and goes okay buck
while you go out and throw the tee shirts
and then you bring up Roy and I went
out and it was seven minutes but I fucking
crushed like just when you need that
one set to go right. And every syllable,
every fucking karma is perfect and I
demolished in front of DL ugly and I walk
off stage and book wows is see you Monday
morning and that's how I got radio.
It's just what were you going
to do? Not fucking book me.
I'm already not really working the comedy
club. I'm already not hired by you.
What is the penalty for this lie? Is
this lie? Will this lie send me to jail?
No, can lie. It's a hustle lie. Yeah.
I'm not saying load your resume with 50
different credits that you don't have,
but if you've performed somewhere
else outside of where you're from,
you have performed
across the country. Yeah.
What you basically did is like the comedy
version of a subprime mortgage loan.
You're like he sold the house to someone
who really shouldn't be buying that
house, but it worked out and he
kept the house. Yeah. That's amazing
man. I just, I came up man, cause
you know I got arrested when I was,
when I was 19 so for the credit card
fraud we were still in credit cards and
college and like buying
jeans and all of that shit.
So my first two years of
standup I was on probation.
So when you have that,
I could have gone to jail or
this shit could be a lot worse.
Living in the back of your mind
forever hustling like, I don't know,
people got the hustle. I'm just
like, no, this is, I have no choice.
I have to fucking do.
I knew a dude who was one of the
original credit card fraudsters.
His name was international Sal
international style. Yeah, yeah,
yeah man.
He was a dude who used to come to this
pool hall I was at and international Sal
was like, uh, he was a real nice guy,
but he was a famous loser
at gambling and that would,
he would make millions of dollars
on credit card fraud. He had,
they had an organized crime empire and
this what they would do back in the day,
you remember they had this transparency
like they would run your card,
they'll put it on a machine and go,
chill, shoot, shoot. Yeah. Carbon,
carbon Heartland. They
would take those carbons,
people who worked in these department
stores would take the carbons and sell
them to him. He would take those carbons,
make a totally new credit card out of
that car with some sort of machine,
and then they would
distribute them to these guys.
They would buy goods with this stuff and
then they would sell the goods and then
guys would come to him in the pool
hall with paper bags filled with cash.
And all he wanted to do was gamble
on pool and he could never win.
And when I'm telling you never,
when that guy was playing with
dirty money and he knew it,
his head was fucked up.
He would be staring that nine ball would
be in the hole and he would be like a
foot away from it and you see his
hand shaking and you're just changes.
Just fuck it up and hit the rail. It
bounce it off. And people would go, no,
he his tick,
I can't fucking believe he missed an
international Sao. Could never win.
He could never win. But he
was one of the original dudes.
Did you find something from him?
Something very weird just happened.
What happened? So I'm typing, I'm
typing international Sao, right.
And I hit space bar
and two things come up.
Credit card thief and pool player.
But when I click the search for that,
nothing shows up. Huh? Like for instance,
credit card thief and it just brings up
a bunch of other stuff about credit card
thieves and other people.
Honestly, it might be because us,
I've not, I'd never looked her up before,
but the search might exist because of us
because I know other international Sal
before and him being a credit card,
these people fled. My friends.
Mom was actually taking care of
him when he was in hospice. He was,
he had cancer. He died of rectal cancer.
God damn Sal. Yeah, it was bad.
It was bad. Tara. No, no, no.
Salbi terrorists. A famous pool player.
This international style was not a
famous Salbi terrible international South
couldn't win, but he was one of the
original credit card fraudsters.
He went to jail for quite a long time
with and then got out and was doing the
same goddamn thing again. What's crazy
though is that when you get arrested,
especially for like some
white collar shit like that,
like what they don't tell you about
getting arrested is that the first thing
they do is try to pin
other unsolved shit on you.
So before you even like
get a mugshot or anything,
you just go sit in a room and they go,
here are all the mugshots of other people.
We are looking at for similar crimes.
Do you know any of these motherfuckers?
Then you get a handwriting sample
and then a as in like there's,
and that's when you find out like,
Oh I was just a petty fucking teenager
that just took her credit card to get
some jeans and then you
start realizing like,
Oh there's an entire fucking syndicate
of shit happening in this city that I
didn't know anything about. They're
trying to fucking pin on me.
And that's when the fear set in. Cause
like in your hair you're like all right,
well I know I probably won't go to
jail. I hope I don't go to jail.
Oh shit. I might go to fucking
jail for some shit he didn't do.
Oh they don't care. They do
not go. And that's when sided,
you're already a criminal. And
that's when I got into comedy. Ooh.
That was the fucking depression. Like
that was the fucking moment like Oh shit.
Well Joey Diaz went to jail for armed
kidnapping. That's how he got into comedy.
He robbed the dude over some
Coke with a machine gun,
taped him to a chair and shit.
And then when he was in jail,
he learned how to do stand up. That
is the best cold open to a biopic.
When Joey Diaz gets this biopic, it has
to start with duct tape on somebody.
The duty kid now he
took pictures together,
didn't he put it up on his Instagram?
He took pictures with the guy who
kidnapped. He's like 31 years ago. I kid,
not this cocksucker our friends.
That's the beautiful thing.
No man is the redemption and being able
to make a mistake and get back in the
mix. Well,
some of the greatest discipline people
good went to jail because they were like
Bernard Hopkins, one of
my all time favorite.
He's one of the greatest
middleweight champions of all time.
And Bernard Hopkins spent like six
years in jail for armed robbery and he
learned how to be disciplined when he
was in jail and when he got out of jail,
he not, not only did he have like a
drive that other people probably couldn't
comprehend, but he knew what
would happen if it went bad again.
He knew what would happen if he slid
back down that road again and apparently
like legs, a corrections officer
to said when he was getting out,
you'll be right back in
here. And he was like, fuck,
I will be the fuck I will be.
And turned out to be one of the greatest
boxers of all time. There he is.
Joey's with the guy. 32 years
ago I made a mistake. So what?
It's not where you start. [inaudible]
showed up to my show 32 years ago.
I made a mistake so wide. His
dad's way of finish. That is crazy.
You know, that's, that's what
the whole redemption is about.
And [inaudible] you know, do what
you can, which is second chance.
That's why I'm just trying to
grind man. All this shit is a gift.
I could have been in prison for
whatever reasons I didn't get sent to
want people to have
redemption. It's interesting.
This culture today wants people to be in
trouble for things they did in the past
and you have to be who you were 30
yeah. Yeah.
We all go to church and
ask for forgiveness every
Sunday for an opportunity to
be forgiven for what we were that week.
Well, the idea that no one, no one
gets a chance to redeem themselves.
It's a terrible world.
Like that's one of the best things about
Christianity is the idea that you have
redemption, you confess
your sins and you move on.
I just think that it's all
new and I think there'll be a,
I think it's all new.
I think there'll be a market correction
at some point because as a society we
are obsessed with who
you were. Credit reports,
rental history, drug
history, employment history.
Fucking you sit down with somebody
who want to know your dating history.
So I can,
Twitter is just racism history
or your bat joke history.
It's, it's,
it's an opportunity for the first time
as a society to audit your past behavior
when all we do is judge who you
are now based on who you were.
That's what our society
is established upon.
So that's why it doesn't feel so out
of pocket to me that people don't,
it's like Oh it's a new
way to see if you were me.
I can literally search your name plus a
word and see if you say it the word and
then I will fucking name no different
than African bankruptcy sitting on your
record from, I like how you described it,
market correction cause I think
that is what's going to happen.
We're going to understand that what
we're doing now is kind of unsustainable.
Like going back and judging someone on
some shit that happened in high school or
whatever it was and and try to look at
words you said when you're trying to make
a joke, like what happened with Kevin
Hart and apologize for it many times.
And then he's hosting the
Oscar and they like, look,
10 years ago he said this and he's
like, look, I'm not going to do this.
I'm not going to do this again. I
already apologize for those things.
I'm going to move on. Sorry.
And the Oscars got fucked.
They went up to have a no host. Now
did we get fuck did the opposite
fucker stand ups get fucked
cause the Emmy's don't have a host
now either. It's good. Good. Listen,
listen, I love Sebastian.
I love Sebastian,
but Sebastian made me cry when I
was looking at this fucking video.
Musical world ward. He's going to have
the amaze. Yeah, he's hosting that shit.
And there's some thing, this
is what comics do. We host.
We don't get the chance to make the jokes.
Nobody wants to make Sebastian sold
Madison square garden out four times.
Yeah, the fuck is he doing
hosting the video music awards?
I want to sell it out. Six. Why
else do it? Why else do it? Let
me show it to you before you,
before you cast any judgment, go
to it. Go to Sebastian's page.
There's like a thing
where he's like asking,
he's asking Jimmy Kemo how to do
it. It's like dog, get out, get out.
Of course they're forcing them to
do a bunch of shit. That's not good.
That's not terrible brand for him,
right? No, it's not a brand for anybody.
Tear. No. There's certain who
else is going to roast that shit?
Who else is going to show up and
you get a roasted? He's a nice guy,
so that's just not going to go shit.
Look, if you got on the first promo,
he roasted himself for even being there
in the first place. Yeah, that's okay.
But if you will,
some show face roast people like of Ricky
Gervais' was hosting something that's
different. A totally. They'll get
mad at him and he goes after him.
That's his brand. He is cutthroat. Yeah.
Shit's on everybody cleaning himself.
I don't know. I just,
I've always enjoyed comics being able
to have that to just go to whenever.
Like if you look at the history of the
Oscars, it's almost always stand ups.
A lot of times I just don't give a
fuck about award show. So there it is.
That's the truth. Yeah. That's the real
truth. It's not even the award host.
It's why the fuck are we doing this thing?
And I would see Chris rock prepare
for these award shows. I'm like,
you're Chris rock.
You couldn't pay me to come anywhere
near one of those stupid fucking shows.
If I was Chris rock,
Chris rock walked out at the NAACP
awards and did a Jessie Smollett,
nobody else's going to
give you a I. You laughing,
look at you enjoying
that shit's different.
No other comic is going to
give you that. That's true.
What is the worst possible thing that
could be said in this room full of black
people that hold him and that she'll say
crit and he fucking say there right to
it. He went right to it. I just don't
think Kevin would have done it. No.
Kevin would've done that. Kevin
would've done that at the Oscars,
but Eddie Murphy had done it. You
see Eddie Murphy when he did that,
when he got that everybody
went after bill Cosby.
It was just a quick little loose
solid jet. But it was great. Yeah,
it was great. What he's talking about.
And then making them give him
back his awards like Ooh, yeah.
Um, wait. Does who come back from that?
Oh, does Jesse Small that you can't,
right? Yeah. You can come
back from everywhere.
Black people are the most
forgiving genre of people.
R Kelly still sells tickets
now, right? No, no, no,
no. He did come back hard though. That
is amazing, Kelly. So tickets time,
everybody saw the piss tape. He had
supporters. That is a Raymond in Brooklyn.
Yes.
Yeah. Black aunties. Deaf. Not be, but
then, so if you're telling me justice,
Molly can come back and telling a lie
on the streets of Chicago and taking a
look. Wicked Huizar Kelly, that's
not as good as R Kelly. But Kiki,
he can get cast in some Jesus movie and
diction and it'll parallel and he'll be
fine. Meaning that anything happened?
The problem is that the people that could
give him the redemption or some of the
people who's trustee portrayed, right.
That's the problem is that you started
looking at the lead Daniels in the Tyler
Perry's and you know,
maybe the Ava DuVernay's and the people
that are in that world of black cinema,
they could get them back in to whatever
this crossover mainstream world is.
So it's about earning that trust
again. But I think there's no,
and I'm just saying from
personal experience, you know,
there's no group of people more forgiving
than I think black entertainment.
I don't think they're ever gonna forgive
him for calling himself the gay Tupac.
I don't think gay people
would give them for that.
And that's for gay people to decide.
I'm a Tupac fans a different way.
What the fuck?
Why the fuck did you just
say, yeah, he's gone.
But then you sit down on somebody's couch
and you go, you, that was the old man,
the new mean now. And then
you come out with your wife,
you do some selfies on
Instagram kissing. Yeah,
but he's not going to have a wife,
boyfriend, husband. Okay, fine.
Whatever it is,
come out and be happy and normal in some
level of attrition for what happened.
He didn't have to like explain the
whole thought process for putting on the
hoax. Why he kept the news
on his neck. Of course,
talking to the cops while I
was holding the subways. Yes,
you got to get drug through the mud. Yeah.
Come on out and get this dragging and
then get back to work and nobody's going
to care. Five, 10 years from now,
nobody's going to care. Good actor.
I thought he was fine on empire. Empire.
It wasn't my cup of tea after a couple
of seasons, but I mean it was fun.
Show was entertaining. Little acted I, I
never looked at it and went, Oh my God,
it's fucking,
it's not like I'm looking at it like some
self produce Netflix movie where I go,
how the fuck did this get on online?
He's still saying that he
didn't do anything right.
He's still saying that he actually
got mugged. I haven't kept up with it.
That's one of those stories where
after he got clear at the first time,
I quit clicking on links and then the
city of Chicago started soon when the city
of Chicago decided to Sue him for the
cost of the investigators item done.
Yeah.
There's just certain shit I don't click
on anymore and just as smelly stories,
I just said, is he in a new movie
out? I don't want to read it.
That's the only thing I need to know.
Yeah, I get it. I think. I think,
I honestly feel like there is a way, bang.
Marv Albert was vice for people on
the back where he's wearing a dress,
so there's a way back in attainment.
There's always a way back.
This is a way back for what's his face
from the fucking, what's his name?
The Matt Lauer is there way back for
that guy. Oh, I don't know about Dallas.
That's why when I'm fucking around
hone and justice Molay was lying
on two Nigerians, the curb. That's
Matt Lauer do. He just got labeled
up. Fuckers up in the room.
Can't be just hitting the
child. That's the narrative.
But apparently all those
executives had that button.
They all had that button to lock the
door and use it to grab the ass. Did,
did I try not to bring that
up? Did I bet they did.
I bet a lot of them are
sweating it out right now. Um,
they lock somebody in the room. Is
there a way back from Matt Lauer?
I don't know if it is a long road.
The problem with Matt Lauer
is I was talking about this
last night or different,
the small Lake, he knows
he owned any of it.
Here's the problem. He
doesn't do anything.
He doesn't do anything that a regular
person can't do. He just talks to people.
He doesn't do anything. He doesn't sing.
He doesn't tell jokes. He can't paint.
So he's replacing, making motorcycles.
Yeah. What do you do? That's so awesome.
He doesn't do anything that everybody
can't do. Everything he does,
anyone can do. He's talking to people.
That's all he does is like, hi,
I'm Matt Lauer with good morning America.
Whatever the fuck the show was today.
So today's show, hello, how are you?
He just talking and he's talking
is bland and non spicy as possible.
But in the, in the,
so you think he's, cause they replaced
him. Was it a, was Carson Daly,
was that kinda who they
used for awhile and today?
I don't know why I'm asking you. I know
you don't wash this shit in the morning.
I had Carson daily and
my girl had this shit on.
Daley had this one show that
was on forever. Yeah. Last call.
Like one o'clock in the morning that
no one watched but it stayed on. Yeah.
For years. They just started the
morning show for a long time too. Yeah.
Does like special interest pieces? Yeah.
He's been in a mix. Oh, I didn't know.
Yeah. Last call. You're making that
up. No, no, they just turned it.
Matter of fact, they just turned
last call over to a new house.
They gave it to a Lilly
Singh. Mm. So there's,
I don't know. I don't know. I
don't know. Cause here's the thing.
For there to be a path back,
there has to be, what is,
what does redemption and ownership
of whatever you've been accused of.
Look like, right. Because if you're in,
this goes back to the whole
redemption conversation.
Is it about your truth or is it about
the truth of your accusers or is it about
what society perceives you as right?
Or the combination of those? Correct.
Because if you don't believe,
if you don't agree with what
your accusers said to you,
then you're already fucked because that's
part of the redemption is respecting
their truth.
Even if it's not true to you and it's
not what you believe happened and what
went down when you hit the shot out
like you did to the teacher. Correct?
Similar. Correct. It's
just, Hey, I'm sorry.
Right now granted, I don't know if Matt
Lauer would be saying that sincerely.
I was sitting like, look, what can
I do to show attrition to move back?
Because now even if you've had
that with the, with your accusers,
society at large still gets to decide
cause the same way society decides who
wears the crown, I get to decide
who to take the crown from short.
You you do about that. Right. So
I mean that's in a fucked up way.
That's the game. I hope I'll
be saved up enough money.
He saved him the money he made. He
was making ungodly something. What?
I fucking go spend your money. Just
relax. Go spend your money. But that's,
that's ego.
But that's ego in feeling like I deserve
to be [inaudible] took it and did it.
Damn it. Diamond [inaudible]
turn off fucking employment.
It's also, you get used to that gig of
being that guy who was on TV. Hello.
Good morning everyone.
Welcome to the today show.
Today we have Tom cruise.
I'll never forget him and Tom cruise
arguing over whether or not Brooke shields
should take antidepressants. That's a
real, that's a real clip. Oh, crazy.
Yeah, they're, they're arguing
over it and it's so strange.
Him and Matt Lauer and Tom cruise and
Tom cruise is telling Matt Lauer he's
being glib. Who? Being glib. Matt,
you're being glib. Cause ma ma,
you know Tom cruise is like, he's
a Scientologist and they don't,
they don't believe in
pharmaceutical drugs.
They don't believe in antidepressants
or psychiatry. There it is right there.
There's the two of them arguing
and Matt Lauer has got that.
I'm thinking cause I'm holding a pen
and pieces of paper war the world.
That's early art. It was a
big deal. It's a big deal.
It fucked a Tom Cruise's career for a
long time as people like this guy's a
fucking nut. Plus they talking about
somebody else's business though. I,
I'm talking about, he had
talked about it publicly.
He had talked about the mistake
that she's making by taking, uh,
antidepressants. Okay. Say, yeah, yes,
that's it. Then I saw in the game,
well the psychiatry, psychiatry
is the enemy of Scientology.
They have all these, um,
they have a big science of psychiatry
kills and it's like someone would like an
electric fucking shock thing in their
head going, ah, it's like in Hollywood.
Like they're, they're on this crusade
against SA against psychiatry.
It's like a big part
of what Scientology is.
The thing that makes me laugh is
that I don't see a lot of Southern
Scientologists.
I don't see a lot of Scientologists
the big things in Clearwater.
That's the number one headquarters.
Clearwater, my sister lives down there.
She lives real close to where
the num, the headquarters is.
It's fucking weird down
there man. Everybody just,
they're all walking
like they got a secret.
Do you, do you think in this society,
do you think Scientology will
be the last religion created?
Like when you really think
about how recent Scientology is,
it's like the 1940s or fifties somewhere.
Not like, it's roughly the same age.
Just like, I don't know. I can
United airlines, Delta airlines,
like it's not an old religion. We have
videos of the guy who made it. Yeah.
Yeah. Will that be the last
religion that is like create it? No.
Cause every other religion
is like old school. You know,
centuries and millennials old, but
no, there'll be new ones.
The interesting thing is they're probably
the last ones to get task tax exempt
status because their tax exempt
status is being questioned right now.
Like there's people that
very angry about it,
but they did it because they all started
lawsuits against the IRS and they
started thousands of lawsuits.
The idea was that they were going to
Sue the IRS into recognizing them as a
legitimate religion and the way to
do that was just overwhelm them with
litigation and that's what they
did, right? Yeah, they still do.
That's what they did.
They then they achieve tax exempt status
a long time ago there. They're very,
it's a very strange, have you ever
read, I'm going clear, I saw the,
this HBO thing, it's the doc is great.
The book is even crazier because Lawrence
Wright goes into depth with all these
different people that were like, as they
were realizing that it was horseshit.
Like as they were getting like the,
the ninth level of doom papers open up
and it's handwritten nonsense by a retard
like that. That guy who
wrote it was a, he was self,
he was like self-diagnosing all of his,
his own personal ailments and dealing
with them himself and then trying to like
pass that off as like a way to live
amongst all these people that were paying
attention to him. But all of it started
for him from himself diagnosing.
Is it? Is it natural for
Scientologists and I'm only,
I only know what I know from that doc
and Leah remedying within lifetime shade.
Is it natural to not be like the way a
Christian is just openly Christian? Just,
Hey, how you doing? The Lord loves
you. I'm here to tell you about Jesus.
I don't really feel like
you get that from science.
Like normally what I like
and watching that doc,
I didn't know the dude from Chicago
PD used to be like the gritty.
Yeah, detective guy. Yeah.
Oh damn. I know you used
to be a Scientologist,
but you'd never find out that somebody
was into that shit until after they're
out of it
now. I think people keep it tucked.
It's not like Mormons where they riding
the bikes and you know what the fuck the
deal is. Yeah. Now they keep it tucked in,
but I think back in the day they used
to talk about it as openly as Poe.
They'd proselytize, they
try to get you to join,
but how like just calm.
Just try and try to get people
to come to these events,
try to get people to come
to these free workshops,
all these different things on
anxiety, different things on the mind.
Dianetics that's what he did.
Decided to write about Dianetics and it's
like the science of cleaning your mind
and avoiding all external influences
that are negative and that are ruining
your, your perspective. And
you said B commercials for that.
And in the eighties and nineties
damn man, I bought it.
I bought a Dionex book.
I got on the list with the volcano
exploding in the commercial.
I remember I bought everything
man. I bought Tony Robbins shit.
I bought all kinds of, I bought book of
five rings. I bought fucking art of war.
I bought everything. I was just trying
to figure out like what's the best,
I was into psychology when I was young
because I was fighting all the time and I
was always scared.
So it was trying to figure out this gotta
be a way to like overcome these mental
hurdles. Like does that was like
for martial arts competition.
The big thing was the fear and wasn't
your physical ability wasn't as much of a
hurdle as the fear, you know,
if the, the fear of competition was
terrible. So I was like, it's good,
but sometimes I feel confident and it'd
be great and other times it'd be fucking
terrified and like what got to
figure out how to be consistent.
So I started getting into all that kind
of stuff and then when I came to LA, um,
it's like in 94 I saw Dianetics
commercials said fuck it, I'll order that.
So I got this little wave, the questions
you seek the answers to here it is.
Can word said during an operation harm
you later page one 82 is it possible to
increase intelligence page one 22 I was
like, Oh my God, ed. Yeah, look at that.
Tauntaun ah, Dianetics bro.
Be like a fucking volcano takeover. Yeah.
I was like thinking that I was going
to be able to figure out all my mental
problems through this book.
And then I got on the list and like every
week I got some new workshop to go to
or this I just put it there. Just
a male, female or male, just male.
This is the 90s that's all they did was
just mail you shit and, but Oh my God,
I got, I wanted this.
It wasn't until I moved and one
of the reasons why when I moved,
I didn't forward my mail. I contacted
all the companies because of Dianetics.
I'd get so much shit from them.
Really? It was the fucking,
that much shit. It was so much shit.
It was like letter after letter,
like the grocery store. Also,
it started freaking me out that they
knew where I was. Like it bothered me.
It bothered me. Like it bothered
me that I was on a list.
I was on a list of someone who bought
the book but didn't go to any classes and
they knew where I was like
maybe I could get them,
maybe they would just
knock on his door. Hey,
do you want to clean up your brain?
Hey, come on, we've got the solution.
Don't you want to be a volcano?
That's scary bro. Yeah, that's scary.
There's a lot of people
get sucked into that man.
I met quite a few people
that were Scientologists. I
was in the summer, the um,
[inaudible] I call it the, you
can do it, motivational stuff.
And I remember in high school,
um, I J ROTC commander w used to,
he used to make us watch this guy
think his name was Bob Malott.
[inaudible] M O w a D Bob
Malott if I'm not mistaken.
He was a Vietnam vet and he like survive
like a terrible white phosphorous
grenade accident and suddenly like
get fucked up real bad in Vietnam.
But it was now doing motivational
speaking and once a month we would watch
videos of this dude. And
like it just starts in a way,
like if you get into one,
you can kind of start getting in
line with the next and the next.
And I think before you know it,
that's when you're into Dianetics land
before you've realized like you can find
someone that's meaningful
with a meaningful message.
And then as you progress more
and more, is that all right?
I agree with less and less of each
author that I'm starting to fuck with.
And so it ended up Bob Malott and Dan
like I think Dave Ramsey started foe
financial shit. Yeah. Well when I was 21
and I was first starting to do comedy,
that's when I was really devouring as
much of it as possible cause I was trying
to figure out like how to not
be so lazy, how to be motivated,
how to get shit done and how to,
how to like find the correct path
and think about things correctly.
And so I, that's when I really
got into [inaudible]. Yeah,
I would follow all those personal power.
Like you had workshops that you would
do like a little like notebooks and shit
fill out and things to talk about
and things to concentrate on.
Like if you did do it, it would help
you. But really what it's all about,
it's just getting your
shit together and moving.
Just go do something like what you did
by taking a job when you would show up at
a gig and you'd be working there Tuesday
through Sunday and then take a day job
and work nine to five.
That is more hustle and more hustle
mindset than anything you're ever going to
get out of an Anthony Robbins book.
Like that is like just doing it.
Just doing it makes you do
more, like do more hardship,
makes you do more hard shit.
Understand that you want it bad so
you're willing to put in the work and do
things you don't want to do.
It's what makes you have that confidence
that you know how to push through and
the the, the mentality that I'm
the type of do to get shit done.
Like I'm gonna show,
I'm not going to waste my day just
sitting around a fucking hotel room.
Now I'm gonna go to work,
I'm going to work all day.
I'm gonna drive five hours and keep that
radio gig and then dry fires and spent
10 hours of the fucking 24 in a day
in a goddamn car to do gigs forward.
Focus just to do gigs. Keep that radio
kid. Yeah. Those things are every,
like I had a guy on yesterday,
this guy Dan Crenshaw,
he's a Congressman who's also a Navy seal.
When we're talking about 'em mentality,
I'm like, when you went through buds,
is there, do they teach you how to
think or do they show you by example?
They don't teach how to
think. They just show you.
They harden you through all that
work and through all that work,
do that insane hell week.
All the shit that you have to do
when you go on through buds training,
the six months of breaking you down and
building you back up, they teach you.
You could do anything just
by my making you do anything,
so you will understand how
you can pass your limits,
what you thought your limits
were, are no longer your limits.
That's what I feel like is missing from
a lot of people that are getting into
motivational this motivational
that they ain't doing shit.
You got to go do something.
That's the number one thing right?
Is fucking action. Take action.
Do you believe that people that aren't
as successful as you think they should be
are qualified to be
motivational speakers? No.
No motorcycle. Yeah.
Most people who are doing motivational
speaking should stop. They should stop.
You're just robbing people. You're
not even motivated yourself.
Like I want to see, I want to wake you
up at three o'clock in the morning. I go,
come on man. We're going
running like, let me see.
You want to see what you do when you're
tired. Let me see how you push yourself.
Come on man. Get up. Get up again
tomorrow. Get up again tomorrow.
Get up again tomorrow. The next day. Get
up, get up, get up, get up, keep going.
How long can you maintain
a positive attitude?
Where's all his teaching it teaching
people you can't do shit yourself.
They you need to show
people that you could do it.
The best motivational speakers to me
are guys like David Goggins cause that,
that guy that that's and that
fucking, that coin right there.
That guy does it every
day and he's got videos.
He just did a a hundred
mile race the other day.
Put up the results on Instagram.
You could see him showing up
22 hours after the race starts.
He finishes a hundred miles. Like
those type of people. Those are motor.
If you ever, you ever seen Goggins is a
Instagram page, but this is insane bro.
He's a fucking animal. This motherfucker
got abs on a coin. He's an animal.
He's got the world record
chin-ups in in 24 hours.
He did some preposterous number
of chin-ups. What's that?
I believe he was beat recently. Somebody
beat him. I think so. I have it. Yeah,
we'll probably come back back. Yeah,
but it's those types of people.
Those are real motivational speakers
cause they're actually doing something.
There's a lot of people that
are teaching you motivation.
They don't have a business. They don't,
they're not their businesses motivation.
Like it's a weird
business. It's like yeah,
it's like teaching someone how to
drive a race car. You never drove one.
But see that's why. And that
goes back to the whole for me,
the whole New York versus LA
thing. In terms of comics,
you just be around other the
comics that are just doing,
like when you see David tail, like
you'll see David Taylor in February,
you'll see them do 20 minutes, right?
And then you'll see him in March,
you'll see them do a totally different
20 and then you'll see them three months
later and he's taken two pieces of the
five minutes from those first 20 and put
it with a new killer. Fucking 30 and
I'll go, what happened to the 20 Oh yeah,
that stuff wasn't tight enough. And
it is, but this joke, this is it.
And when he breaks down,
why that joke that you love doesn't even
fucking mattered to them because it was
to get to this like that. You can't
teach that. You can't explain it,
but you can show it. And then I can
go home and go, fuck, I need to write.
I need to go back and look at my
old shit and figure out a way.
David tells one of the rare
guys that became an alcoholic,
sobered up and got better, right?
Like usually the guys who are
drunk are fucking hilarious.
And then they stopped drinking and they
get boring. Yeah, he got the opposite.
He became a way better comic
titer and just punchlines. And
people say that about M and. M they
say they don't. Once he sobered up
and what? Clean these better?
No, that it was worse. Yeah.
That's what usually happens.
So it happens to everybody.
It happened at Kinnison happened to
bill Hicks. It happened to everybody.
I never had on, not,
not necessarily Hicks.
I've never had alcohol, a love
alcoholic. I'll drink here and there.
But I used to get pissed in my twenties
when I would go on stage drunk or tipsy
or whatever the fuck.
And then after the show people would
give the liquor credit for me being funny
and it used to offend me. So
that's why I stopped drinking.
Wow. Okay. Fuck. Gave credit to the list.
You're so funny. When you joined, this
was funny. You should drink more or the,
you know, on these road rooms,
they'll sing you shots cause
you're on stage with Jack.
And they've associated
that as part of the,
so also you lose control of the audience.
At least I do when I'm up there
drinking because then this is a shot.
Someone else sends a shot and now
it's a fucking date. It's a rock.
It's a pep rally. It
started about, yeah, when
people are sending you
shots, that's a disaster.
That's a disaster because then
everybody wants to send you a shot.
But then what am I doing in my performance
that made someone think it was cool
to do that and that that would make
this experience better for everybody.
You're doing a Bert Kreischer,
you turn it into a party,
take your shirt off at the story,
my style and hollering at each other
to shut the fuck up so I can get this
chisel shit out of my mouth. So I, uh,
so it totally changed how I, you know,
and also alcohol makes me sleepy and then
it was too much driving in the 20s and
stuff. So I can't be drowsy,
hit it home. So I don't know.
It was just never my thing.
Yeah, it's a tricky one man.
Because like one drink will
loosen you up two drinks. Ah,
now again, a little silly. Three
drinks. Now you're kind of drunk,
you know when you could still do
it. But is it as good as one drink?
No it's not. But once you get
one drink and you get happy,
you want another drink, fuck off another
one. And then next thing you know it,
you're a little drunk and you're
on stage. Like I'm at that age now.
I can't remember what comic did a joke
like this, but maybe a couple of them.
But we're before you drink,
you have to look at your schedule for
the next day and a half to make sure you
have the bounce back and recovery
and all of that shit. Yeah.
It's not just can I go out Friday? It's
what am I doing Saturday and Sunday?
Well, you're a goal-oriented guy. It
seems like for goal oriented people,
the alcohol is one of the biggest
impediments. You know, the craziest thing.
And the only thing I've never been able
to make proper time for in my career is
exercise. Really? Yeah. Why not?
I'm not good about exercise
because they're a trainer.
You've got money cause it's a
that still, I don't have time.
There's the time and so and my brain,
it's while I'm at, when I'm going on,
when I was still living in LA,
I had a trainer and I got to New York
and then it's must do this. Must write,
must watch the video.
If I exercise I will be too tired
and then productivity will go down.
And when I know deep down when
I exercise, I'm more creative.
The brain juices and shit work more.
But it's the only thing that I've never
been able to like properly regiment in
my life. Well this is how you fix that
force yourself. Like we're in August.
Okay. We have a what? Six more
days? Seven more days of August,
something like that. What is
today? 10 more days. 10 more days.
Say the 21st so we have 10 more
days. August. Do you just say,
at the end of this fucking month,
I am going to have a trainer and I'm
going to work out three days a week with
that trainer, period. This
is how we're going to do it.
Write it down and then just get it
done and force yourself for one month,
for one month, for the month
of September for that month.
You have to work out three days a week
and you write it down and then publicly
stated so that you can't back out of it.
Put it on Twitter or put it on Instagram.
Take one of those shirtless
pictures of my gut, just profile,
show everyone and let them
clown me. But if you do that,
you'll force yourself to do it. And
next thing you know you've done it.
You know like I have this dog
that loves running and so I'm,
I make sure that if I don't
take him running, he's,
he's always a pain in the ass. He's
dropping the ball on the table,
trying to get you to play. Like
he's a very energetic. Yeah.
So like that motherfucker makes me run
five days a week, five days a week.
I get up, I'm like, come on bro,
let's go, let's go. He goes crazy.
He starts running around in
circles. He and then, and then we,
we go hit the trails. Is this the dog
that you saw? What was it? What was it?
A snake or some shit you ran over
while you were jogging one day.
Like [inaudible] dog. Yeah. That was a
different dog. Yeah, that was crazy, man.
I jumped over this log and as I was
jumping over this long, I'm like,
that's how rattlesnake it was.
Fat dude. Like my forearm.
I was like fuck one of the biggest
snakes I've ever seen in terms of
rattlesnakes. It was big
like six feet long, big.
That is a big fucking snake. And he
was just laying flat out on the road.
Like a stick. Just warming. Yeah.
And the dogs went right over it.
They didn't even notice it cause it
was just completely flattened out.
I was literally in the air over it
before. I'm like, Oh my God. Yeah.
That was a different one. Man. I've
killed a bunch of rattlesnakes.
Men always seeing those fuckers.
There was one in my neighborhood real
recently where there's a video of a Bobcat
and a rattlesnake duking it out
in the middle of the street,
like telling them they fucking a mile
from my house and man, it's crazy.
Freaking coyotes out here, man. There's
a lot of weird wildlife out here.
You know California's got weird wildlife.
There's a lot of shit out there.
A lot of Bobcats and mountain
lines. What did we have down South?
We just said squirrel. So
that was the only little
[inaudible] that shit. You guys have
coyotes now. Kylie's are everywhere.
They have coyotes in every fucking
state. 50 States probably eating them.
I fucking coyote saying, Oh yeah,
for sure. People eat coyotes.
There's someone eating a
coyote right now. Right now.
While we're someone listening to
this right now. Jerky, not bad.
I guarantee you one of your listeners
knows a person that makes a coyote jerky.
Probably. Yeah, I'd try that
shit. My friend Steve Rinella,
who's going to be here tomorrow,
he cooked and ate a coyote on TV.
They wanted to see what it tasted like.
Oh look at this fucker on
a trail near San Diego.
We could go the size of that
chicken fucker. God damn,
it's all curled up and ready to go to,
we're two sprawled out as the society.
Yeah. Well these motherfuckers
are everywhere too and
we need them by the way,
cause that's why there's not as
many rats and rabbits and shit.
It's a whole beautiful
ecosystem out there.
Have you heard the number of rats
they've found out or in LA recently?
I just saw a story about it last
night. It's disgustingly scary.
All at the comedy store.
12 million over 12 million.
They're all the comedies and if they hit
all 12 there's about 1.5% of them that
are, have this disgusting
diseases. And instead,
if it hits over 2% it starts
spreading into people. Oh.
Oh good times, bro. You got
to move to the mountains.
Yeah man. I moved some quotes, bro.
Genetic code to simple that
can freaking reproduce. Yeah.
Sisters and mom is that sisters
and fathers and yeah, no problem.
They have no problem fucking this. No
mutation. Is that true? They don't.
They have like a spreading problems.
That's why they can really dreamless
gestation can be pregnant again.
Three months. Give me pregnant
again. Did you ever see that?
A documentary on Netflix, that
rats documentary? No. Whoo.
You ready for that one? That's
a good one. Write that down.
That one's going to freak
you out because it details,
they catch some of them and they
just run some tests on them.
And this is a in suburban Atlanta and
they find all kinds of crazy fucking
diseases and they have Manhattan,
they show all these rat scrambling over
garbage and into the sewer system and
they show how smart they are,
how they'll send the young
rats to test out poison.
And then the young rats will eat the
poison and die and then the old rats like,
okay, we get it. And then they, they're
smart Daptiv. Yeah man, they're,
they're clever.
I mean there are the most prevalent
mammal in any city. You know,
if you look at any like just sheer
numbers and just we're going to do,
that's a hustle hustler right there.
There's more Brown rat in New York
city than there are human beings.
I think there's more bio mass of rats
than there is bio mass of human beings.
So that means the weight. Yeah, just
the weight. The weight of check volume.
That's true. I might've made that up,
but the biomass of a, I
mean just the sheer numbers,
it's, there's not another other animal
that you can think of that's like that.
What's the remix
of anywhere between eight point 4,000,020
14 all the way up to 33.6 million rats
in New York city. Cheesy.
That's more than there are people
for sure. Yeah. Try 18 million.
God, God, rats.
The documentary's amazing man. They're
vectors of diseases. They've always been,
wasn't carrying diseases.
What's the number of red?
What's the red infestation looking like
in countries where they eat rat stuff?
Interests, disease. Fucking not
a lot of countries eat rats.
He knows the weirdest shit.
You ever seen those temples in
India where they feed the rats?
The rats are everywhere. Dude.
That'll give you the heebie. Jeebies.
These people were drinking out of like
bowls of milk that the rats drink out of.
They like scoop it up. They,
they have all these rats
over like literally running
[inaudible] or is it just this is
your crib either rats, they feed them.
Look at this. What do you got here? Jamie?
Was this rat temple speed up ahead. So
you could see what it's like when the,
all the rats and the
people interact. Yeah.
So they put out food for the rats
and the rats. You could pick them up.
I mean the rats, I have zero fear
of people and in fact they're like,
they get along with people.
So this is like a temple that you
visited in India and fucking rats are
everywhere and everybody
treats these rats with respect.
Very coexisting. Yeah. So the reason
why rats are scared of people,
they recognize that people want to
kill them because they carry diseases.
But in India they just got a
totally different vibe going on.
So look like those pigeons are hanging
around those rants in New York city.
Rats, hunt pigeons. You ever see rats,
killer pigeons and drag them away like,
Whoa. Have you seen the
video of the Pelican?
That aided pigeon swallowed the whole
boom. I saw a Pelican eat a duck,
hold jock. Just pelicans and low
key assholes, assholes, dinosaurs.
Look at these fucking rats, man. They're
everywhere. That's where we're headed.
Rats are pellets. We hit headed with
fucking rats in New York. You think so?
It's just gotta be normal. I mean,
people are gonna try and stomp 'em out
and poison and trap and all of that.
But at some point you just
gotta go high man have hit two.
They're maintaining right now. All
right, you can still go to a restaurant.
You still go to the
movies, still go shopping.
It's all normal and there's millions of
rants running underneath your feet under
the ground. What's, what's the
plan? What's de Blasio's plan?
Yeah, for people. Definitely rats.
Fucking plan. What kind of plan is you
have to take care of his corrupt cops.
Take care of his, uh, all the
problems with the streets.
Take care of all the crime. Take it.
They know rat problems and plans,
but they had like all these studies and
EPA motherfuckers that mr money did they
have,
how much money is Blasio have like how
much money they have to spend on things
like rats. They probably
don't have any budget.
It probably doesn't present
as much of an ominous threat.
This crime or bridges and you know
tunnel shit and takes all you know,
infrastructure probably it would
have to be a pandemic disease,
which as Jamie was
saying can happen there.
We have medieval diseases showing up
here now that particularly in trash and
shit in Hollywood or in downtown
LA with all the homeless people.
It's fucking crazy because people are
literally just shitting on the street just
shitting everywhere. The, the,
the homeless situation in downtown LA
scares me more than the rat situation.
What's the numbers?
Oh you need to send us a thousand have
you ever driven through skid row? Yeah.
Bananas, right? Yeah. Cause
it's close to fashion row.
This are you into fashion? No,
but I was over there one day.
There's thousands and thousands of people
just living on the street. Thousands,
thousands. Like a,
like a whole gigantic theater sells out
and all the people pile out onto the
street, but that's where they live.
That's what it's like. It's like,
like people go into the Verizon center,
like 7,000 people you find
in a few streets and they
think the solution is some
sort of hostels or something that they
can start trying to do. Good luck.
These people have accumulate, they've
like, they've become accustomed, they've,
that's their lifestyle. Like
that's not what they want for sure,
but they're accustomed to being homeless.
Like they've acclimated to that
world and they've lived in it,
many of them for years and years and
years and they go to places in shelters
where they get food, they
sleep out on the street.
They have a whole community of
people that are out in the street.
They're all doing drugs and most
of them are psychiatric patients.
Half of this stuff, a
lot of them ask the thing
that really fucks me up with the
homeless population in this country,
is it half of it? And then on some
mental illness, shit, maybe some of them,
their family just can't give
them the care they need.
But if they got the care they need,
maybe they could be a little more level
enough to at least be under a roof with
the love when a somebody that can afford
to, you know, yes. To take them in.
Yeah,
no, no, I think you're absolutely
right. And in the 1980s they,
some of them have problems that
are solvable. Yeah. Some of them,
but some of them don't have anybody to
help them get through the problem. Sure.
I mean, and then things
deteriorate, you know,
they get worse and worse and
worse. And as you get older,
you lose hope and then you say, this
is me, this is who I am now. Yeah.
There's, there's like, there's,
there's like this weird thing
with the homeless as well,
where I feel like as a country, like we,
we're quicker to help people in
groups like it, like in a weird way,
it still fucks me up and
it's gonna come out wrong.
But if there's a natural disaster,
the amount of money we will pour into
relief and support for particular area
after the hurricane or the tornado
or whatever, and that's fine.
That same type of outpouring happened
just once for the homeless coast to coast.
It would change so much
fucking shit, bro. Yes,
but if people are fucked up in a
group at once, then it doesn't,
it doesn't resonate.
Like when you see a single homeless person
or the news just shows you the row of
tents,
you don't see the person crying with
the rubble behind them and they've lost
everything. It doesn't, for whatever
reason, it doesn't connect the same.
No, you're absolutely right. We need,
like if if something like Katrina
happened or a giant earthquake,
then we would realize
we have to do something,
but if there was no homeless people and
then all of a sudden something terrible
happened and there was 20,000 almost
people wandering around downtown,
we would immediately go, Oh,
we've got to fix this simmering,
slow sort of effect.
It's similar and similar how much
money we spent on other countries,
right? How much money we spend
on aid, how much money we spent,
and we don't fix inner cities that have
been impoverished since the fucking 18
hundreds we don't ever go in
there and try to solve problems.
We don't look at it. I've
been saying this forever,
like if you want a better country,
the best way is to ensure
there's less losers.
And the best way to ensure there's less
losers is give people more opportunities
and fix places where you're,
you have no chance. I mean,
how many people that grow up in,
in neighborhoods where they have no
chance get out. It's like it's a tiny,
tiny fraction of people that wanted
to become successful and happy.
Most of them are trapped by
the environment that they
find themselves just by a
random roll the dice,
they wind up and they're in Detroit and
they're in the worst neighborhood in
Detroit,
or they're in the South side of Chicago
or they're in Baltimore or wherever the
fuck it is, and then no one
does anything to fix it.
No one does anything to change it.
But if there was no place like that and
all of a sudden the disaster happened
and then there was a place like,
then there'd be an outpouring of
contributions and people would want to do
something to try to fix it.
Yeah.
I just think that we live in a society
where it's just the people in power know
that if you help the people
that you've been oppressing,
then you run the risk of facing
their RAF once they have power.
Do you think that's what it is?
To some degree? Why would I,
if I have an opportunity to make something
better and people are labeling me as
the fault for you being in that
situation in the first place,
then I run the risk of losing power
because those people are going to come get
me, they're gonna vote
me out office. So it's,
it's about aligning your views and choices
with the people and it's gonna keep
you in that office.
Yeah, I guess, man,
I just would think that in today's day
and age people would be more forward
thinking and they would think, look,
we've got a lot of problems
with the environment.
We've got a lot of problems with
climate control like we've got,
we've got real issues in this world,
but we also have problems that have been
here forever that no one's done a God
damn thing defense. So
these new people are like,
well the oceans rise and the oceans
rise and what are we going to do?
Like what the, it's not going to
affect all these inner cities,
these inner cities that have
had these same problems forever.
If you looked at the problems like murder
problems in this country, like the,
the places in the inner city where you
have like gang violence and murder and
drug trafficking on the same fucking
problems over and over and over again year
after year,
don't go, go ahead, go.
There's no no effort.
What do I gain if I am,
if I'm a politician and I'm in power,
what do I gain by helping those people?
Well,
you get more people that do well and
you have a better economy and you have a
safer society and people look at you
like you're a real leader. Like, wow,
mayor wood, look what he did. Sure.
If they give me the credit or unless it
gets politically spun the wrong way or
some shit. Yeah, but I mean then I'm out.
That's the case with every single thing
a mayor or governor does. We're just,
I don't know. I just think where
black politics like that is concerned,
we are more than
inclined to vote and do things
that serve our own interest first.
Politicians are more inclined to do,
to enact policies that serve their best
interest and we're more inclined to vote
for things that serve our best interests.
So the two things work against
each other. Then for it to work,
for the system to work,
you got to vote for things
that are for the greater good,
even if it means sacrificing
your own position in the process.
And that's what I think a
lot of politicians don't do
in this day and age.
Trying to help impoverish communities
when now there's an awareness of how long
stuff's been going on. And how do
you know who Michael Wood? Um, jr is,
is that his name? Michael Wood jr.
yeah, he was a cop of Baltimore and um,
he uh, came across um,
this paper from the 1970s that
was detailing like a rap sheets,
all the problems in the, in the
area and all the different crimes.
And he was realizing this is in
the two thousands. He's like,
these are all the same places with the
same crimes that we're handling now.
So here we are 30 plus years later,
the same exact crimes in
the same exact places.
And you'd like the feeling of
like futility, the handling this,
the fact that no one gives a fuck and
that this has been this way forever and
nothing's being done Dawn to do anything
other than just continue the process of
arresting people, letting
them out, arresting people,
letting them out and then it's just chaos.
I'll give you a good example
of self interest. So in Newark,
New Jersey right now they are facing
water contamination levels that are higher
than Flint and there has
been cover-ups out the ass.
That's where I was born. So
well I go get your shit checked.
Get parents to let, it's in the past,
I think it's like past eight
years or so. They're starting to,
they're starting to pull it
the threads now and figure out,
Oh what the hell was this?
What's going on with the water?
And it's all these people getting
fucked up. The people who covered it up,
those, the people in office who could
have made the decisions that you,
that you're saying to not fucking let
fucked up water getting to the water
table. So if a corporation
says, Hey man, fuck it,
don't worry about that dirty water.
Here's some money and some campaign
processing. That's what happened.
I don't think so. I mean you've
got to unravel the story.
We got to see how it unfolds.
But if there is a coverup,
a cover up only happens if
someone has more selfish,
self-serving intentions in mind.
Like the core base of a coverup is to
fuck over somebody who doesn't deserve to
get fucked over. So off that alone,
the choice you're making isn't for the
greater good of the society or the pride
or like the way, and it's like,
you know what ants do is
so dope when it's a flood,
you ever seen the fire and to
make the float? That's what,
that's what we have to be,
but we're not going to beat it cause
nobody wants to be the ant on the bottom.
Drown, might drown and can't
get back up to the top in time.
We don't, we don't do that
well. I think there's
also a sense of futility.
Like there's a lack of resources to
handle everything. So you just take,
take what you can handle,
what you can and keep moving and
then just get the fuck out of Newark.
I mean that's how people look at it.
People look at those neighborhoods
like a place to escape.
Not that it's anything that can be fixed.
Yeah, that's what I,
that's what I struggled
at lit with Birmingham and
terms of going back home and
trying to do things that feed
the neighborhood positively.
Cause I feel like I never had
that growing up. Like, you know,
there were a couple of people and
then you Bo Jacksons and your Charles
Barkley's, they come around and you
know, give a high five to the kid or two.
But to be able to do things that
create opportunities so that,
that feeling of hopelessness
or whatever isn't always there.
Or if there's one thing that can be like
big Sean did something that was dope in
Detroit, he put $100,000
down on a recording studio.
And to help underprivileged kids have
access to just fucking just record,
just to do something
that makes things better.
So the problem is that in the
process of trying to give a fuck,
it's stressful and there are people that
are pushing and working against you and
you could easily just go to sleep in your
bed comfortably at night and just not
care. But I try, I do as
much as I can back home.
But the idea of getting the fuck out,
I'm always torn on because
it's like I'm gone. Um,
if nothing else,
I can pay my bills til I die on and think
my son could go to a decent division
two school and be fine.
But if I'm not using my gifts and all
these advantages to try and help him
better other people somehow, then I
feel like I failed the city. Well,
I feel like I failed where I came from.
So I'm trying to figure out how,
because I don't, I've never,
what I've never seen is someone that
gave back or attempted to put back into
without it costing them
something in the process as well.
Right. I see what you're saying. Like you,
you'd have to make a big sacrifice in
order to help and you'd have to take time
that you don't even have time to work out.
So how the fuck do you have time to
go and save Birmingham? Yeah. Yeah.
That is a problem. I mean,
you have bandwidth, right?
You have a certain amount
of bandwidth in your,
in your brain and how much of it can
you dedicate to charitable things?
How much can you dedicate to
your career, your family, dad?
It's the constant process.
I mean I think it's the job of people
who are running cities and States and the
country, but it's about how much resource,
how much resources they have and how
much did they delegate to fixing these
problems that have existed forever.
What I've learned, man, is uh, I
learned a shit ton. We shot, um,
you shot my comedy central pilot
in Birmingham, um, this summer,
which was not an easy feat in
terms of the logistics of it.
Just cause Birmingham's
not a, it's not Atlanta,
it's not a bunch of fucking
cameras just laying around,
but you start seeing how
different entities of at the
state level and local 11,
leaving the County level all
have to get a little touch.
I'll have to have a hand in it somehow
so that everyone feels like they are all
part.
Like you have to please too many people
at the same time to get anything to get
anything remotely done. I dunno, I
can't speak for the rest of the country,
but I know in Alabama
that's generally how it is.
I think that's generally
how it is with all politics.
I mean everybody wants
a little bit of credit,
everybody wants a little bit of a say in
it, fine but the credit, but just help
get you to credit but help like do
this logistical thing to help that.
Like that's the stuff where nobody wants
to really or you're not sure if anybody
really has genuine intentions on helping.
Yeah, cause not everybody's
happy for you to crib.
That's the saddest shit ever.
When you think about
charitable organizations and
you find out how much people
are making to run those charitable
organizations in palace and shit. Yeah,
and how little the money actually
goes towards the charity. Like Jesus.
Like I know there's going to be
some red tape and bureaucracy,
but it's like red cross, isn't
it? Some insane number. Like,
how much of money from red cross
actually goes towards the actual charity
itself. I'm going to say 10%
that might be generous that,
but that is a crazy number. That night.
It cost 90% of all the money that
comes in just to deal with overhead
sticks and moving stuff
around. And that's why,
that's why I kind of like go fund
me, cause you can just find them.
I fucking be like, here, here's $100
yeah. When there's real problems, what
do you got Jamie? What's the number?
Let's guess type that in. And
it's like stories come about.
The CEO's been serially misleading about
where the 91% of money that they says
goes. I dunno. Oh,
so it's less than 10% 9% 91% there's
91% go somewhere other than the charity.
So it's 9% no, no.
I think they're actually
saying 91% goes to the charity.
We're very proud of the fact that 91
cents of every dollar that's donated goes
to our services. The
services, the services.
Gas. Yeah. Come on. Did you see that?
Do the dinero Deniros suing some lady
that worked for them that watched 55
episodes of friends in a week. No. Yeah,
she embezzled money. Uh,
allegedly embezzled money.
Uh, took, used his miles to
fly on her own personal trips.
She was making 300 grand a year, but the,
the big story that clickbait title was a,
he sued her for $6 million
after a wild friends.
Been she watched 55 out of 55
episodes of it in four days.
That's 2008 so that's DVDs
in 2008. That is hilarious.
So they're still going after it
11 years later. Oh, she began,
she was his assistant in 2008
and then she, and then, okay,
she began as denier as assistant
and she now is being sued.
So she basically got to a place where
they're working together for 11 years and
11 years of employment,
DeNiro Robinson Rose to vice
president of production and finance.
According to this suit, which
lists are 2019 salary, $300,000.
She finally left the company in April
after being suspected of corporate
sabotage, said the legal filing. And
she embezzled money and she went crazy.
Oh seven hours a day. That's
14 episodes. That's doable.
It's doable for four days. I
benched 24 in like a day and a half.
The whole season. The whole season.
Fucking a DVD box at day's
me was also a good show.
It's just funny that I had all
this shit that this lady did.
Apparently allegedly the 55 episodes
of friends are the ones that became the
headline that everybody had to click
on it cause that's the funniest shit.
Watch 20 episodes of arrested
development one day and somebody shot.
So this is you just sitting around
watching TV while she's working for,
what is she supposed to be doing?
Like maybe she's doing research,
maybe she's waiting around for something
to do. What did the real project needs?
Friends research, looking for cast.
I don't know what to Neo
projects are even around. I mean,
well DeNiro is probably trying to figure
out where all his money's going because
he's getting divorced right
now, so he's probably, yeah man,
he's getting divorced.
There was some public spat at a
restaurant where he yelled at his wife,
I wouldn't have to do these shitty fucking
movies if you weren't spending all my
money. Ah, yeah.
Oh, I see that.
I always feel bad for people like
the Cubs second baseman bins.
Obras he's been like, I
don't know what the like, Oh,
physically unable to perform.
Like he's basically been on the disabled
list the entire season while he goes
through and deals with his divorce.
Oh God. Like [inaudible] serious shit.
She going to go make millions of dollars
playing baseball. I can't right now.
I have to go to court and count my
cash and make sure that my shit,
so his disabled shit is just
dealing with the divorce. I forget.
Not even a real injury. No,
it's not a real injury. Well,
I guess it technically
is mental. What it is.
That's a girl taken
apart his puzzle. Yeah.
Took apart as fast as she's doing.
She's taken apart the puzzle of his life
while she's forcing him to go through.
I think it was like infidelity
or something. Somebody cheated.
I had a buddy of mine who, uh,
he had it paid for his wife's lawyer and
you don't even think about it that way.
Like if you're married, you go, well,
who's paying for her lawyer? But bitch,
you're paying for her
lawyer. If she didn't work,
you pay for the general of the
opposing army to try to dismantle you
financially. And he didn't
have a prenuptial agreement.
So he went to a war for fucking years,
years and years and years and
they were trying to drain him.
And the lawyers are smart man. They
know that the real settlement is great,
but what the real money is in legal
fees leading up to the settlement.
They just drag that shit out for a couple
of years, hundreds of dollars an hour.
[inaudible] and next thing you know,
you've lost millions of dollars.
And this guy, you know, busted
his ass 12 hours a day, forever.
Lost almost everything still to this day.
How about this? He's been married for,
I think he's been married
for 14 years to a new woman.
He was with her for 12 years and he has
been paying her alimony than they were
married. Wow.
He's married to a new woman and
didn't even have kids with her,
so he's been paying her
for 14 fucking years.
I'm talking six figures every
year. She doesn't do shit.
She lives in a fat house in the
Palisades. The whole thing is bananas.
You see Larry King is getting a divorce.
Yeah, I didn't know that. He's head.
This is his eighth wife. Yeah. Love
it. I hope he gets another one.
I hope it gets another one and these
are like a skeleton and they have Jordan
walked them out. They're
in an exoskeleton.
I can't prove it,
but I feel like the divorce lawyer
industry is tied to the wedding industry
somehow. Somehow they don't
have to be tied in like legally.
They know they both benefit from one
another. Of course. Yeah, of course.
Look at that perfect relationship.
How'd it go wrong and I just want
to know what the arguments were.
Well, apparently there was infidelity
as well, allegedly. No way.
I can't believe she did cheat on him
on her side or his side. Her side.
Apparently she had a year long affair
prenup in that one and then she looked
fucking hot 20 years ago when they
got married cause she's like 59 now.
So when they first started shacking it up,
she was in her thirties probably look
and smoking. She's pretty pretty lady.
You know, you'd think that's an addiction.
Love the same as any other drugs.
Sure, of course. Yeah.
Most people lose when you're talking
about getting married seven times. Yeah.
It gets a little wacky. Yeah.
He's had marriages that
lasted like less than a year.
They'd get divorced and marry another
one. Right. I would get married
I think once I, if I do it,
it'd be once I know one in me,
one I got one in me.
I was proposed to a girl like can Oh
three those are one of the biggest
mistakes. Almost. Almost fucking me.
How'd you get out of it? It's funny.
She was cheating. Woo.
That's nice. That's a relief.
Yeah.
It was back in a day when you share
cell phone plans and she kept pushing us
over our minutes for the month. I'm
like, what the fuck are you talking to?
So the next month I requested
the full itemized call.
Long be like back in the day,
sprint would send you your
entire call log for the month.
And I just went through it and then I
could see the patterns of when I was sleep
or when I was on stage. You could just
see that when it's all in front of you,
it's easy to just see that. Oh yeah.
When I go to work at 6:00
AM you can call it this.
Wow. Yeah. And it was real easy to
track down. Did you confront? Ah, yeah,
I was, I was a little extra about it, but
I was young. I was fucking
young. Yeah. I called 'em, uh,
call sprint and the, the, I basically
turned my phone into her phone.
Oh shit. And then I started
texting the dudes. Oh, her phone.
How many guys? Those two guys.
Oh. And so I tell both guys
to come over at the same time.
To now, so that those two guys,
which is so catty and me, and of
course they show up, she calls me,
curses me out, and boom,
bam relationship to, Oh,
so you told them to come over
while she was at home. Correct.
But you weren't there. Correct.
Ooh, I like it. No, that's D's.
But in like in the
bigger scheme of things,
if one as it came over and hit
her or done anything stupid,
I'm liable and that, yeah.
Hell yeah. No, come on.
You're not liable for someone calling me.
I'll charge you with murder for
somebody. They shot days. There are laws,
not that I deceive to men, that the
showing up to the fucking house,
he gotta remember my brain is going,
don't go back to jail ever again.
So in my brain, I'm going,
there's something that could have,
that could have gone South somehow.
I don't think you would've got
in trouble for that either way.
I wouldn't want that. I
see what you're saying.
Teamed up by some psycho dude who's
jealous or whatever. I didn't want that.
I was jealous that he's the
other one who's cheating on yeah,
and I have my little $700
engagement ring from the Zales.
I took it back and this is what I learned
that if you returned an engagement
ring, the sales person
loses the commission. Oh,
they take the commission
back out or the next check.
Cause it had been a problem.
He got upset. He wasn't upset,
but he spent like an hour trying to talk
me out of return. Real. Yeah. He said,
man, just go. Think about
it, man. Go think about it.
Did you tell him just walking around
the mall? She's fucking two other dudes.
That's ultimately what I have to do.
And once I told him that he
processed it with no fucking,
I just took the L no pushback.
Yeah. It was a $700 ring.
It's cut was probably only going to
be like, what? 70 $80 what's the cut?
It didn't want to give up
that 80 bucks. I respect that.
He's fucking hustle and he's
selling jewelry in a mall. Yeah.
You don't want to fucking lose
your fucking commission. Yeah.
Those are bad decisions being
made. Buying jewelry in a mall.
It's crazy though. It's more
like, it's like Joey though,
where like she and I are like
pool now. Oh really? Yeah.
Like she's married like it's all. Oh
wow. It's all love now. Wow. That's good.
Look, people grow and learn. Does. That's
hilarious though that you did that.
Yeah, that was, that wasn't my
finest hour, but like I said,
I'm not a fighter.
I figured out a way to die by luckily
construct a situation that tears down your
entire fucking operation.
Yeah. That was a good move.
That's a learning process too, for
hurts like, damn. How could I be so odd?
I mean,
because what I'm going to do drive over
and cuss you out and guru and cheating
them. No, no. We don't all
know about each other. Yeah.
It's time for us all to meet. So Hey
man, come on over to the house. Hey man,
you come on over to the house.
Meet me at 11 don't come too soon.
Come exactly at Alem. Wow. Call sweet.
Want to be there? No.
Some explosions. You just got
to walk away from, no, man,
I don't want to be there for that one.
Nah, that's where it goes. I have never,
that's something I've
never lived down like,
and then it just, it was just ugly.
It was just one of those things
where you just go, you know what?
Maybe I shouldn't have done that.
Her mom's calling me the next day.
Well you just talk to her, talk
to the baby. Oh boy. No man,
I can't like it was did.
It was full blown, bro.
I'm sending pictures of the fucking
ring and all types of stuff. Like, Oh,
you got an extra. Yeah, it was, it
was not, it's not my finest hour,
but don't you think that like those
brutal breakups and all the chaos of
infidelity and all that kind of nonsense,
like it gives you a better understanding
of relationships when they go, well,
it gives you, it's all luck, life
lessons. Like you don't get to be,
you don't get to be a seasoned grown up
human being without getting your heart
broken a few times without having a
bunch of things going on. Disappointing.
In your work life and then then you become
a person with an understanding of all
the variabilities that
you're dealing with in life.
I think the problem though,
you know with love is that it also can
be corroding in a sense where if you've
really been invested and you've really
tried to love and then it didn't work.
I think like I feel like if
you've been in love a couple of,
I also feel like people
get married sooner.
There's something more pure about
it, but people get married later.
It's more honest. Yeah.
Like it's like this blind love and love.
We never been done dirt. Oh my God,
the sky is falling versus you're a
grizzled vet. You've been cheated on,
you've cheated. So you know both sides
of that coin. So you know how it feels.
It like, you know, both sides of that.
So when you enter into a relationship,
it's more pure. But because you have these
battle wounds and these battle scars,
I don't know if you love
the same as the couple.
They got married in their
twenties it's still love
is on who you're with and
how much you appreciate them.
It also depends on where you're at in
your life. Like if you got married now,
you're a successful man. I mean you
did all the grinding and the hustling,
but someone would be entering into your
life now while you're already made it,
you're successful. You're established.
The hustle of getting to there as now,
it's just about about maintaining,
which although difficult,
you have the confidence that it's going
to happen that you don't have in the
beginning, that early days hustling
when you were taking those odd jobs.
Who the fuck knew where
your life was going?
That's one of the
beautiful things about it.
There was gigs I was headed to.
I didn't have gas money to get home and
the gig I was going to was the gas money
to get home. So please don't
cancel and please don't pull some,
some black promoters shit and don't pay
me like I literally need those $40 I
have no way to get home. Wow.
And sometimes you don't get paid and
if you don't get paid on the way home,
you stop at a daily work spot and
you do some yard work or whatever.
Yeah, you go do some daily work real
quick for the day. You miss a day,
you miss a shift at the radio
station, a radio station. Hey man,
I got car trouble in Kentucky. I can't
get home. I'm a mr morning show. Sorry.
I mean you go do some day job,
get your $40 and get home.
But that's a real life experience
that you just can't pay for.
That's so valuable. The
fact that you did do it,
even though it was horrible when it
happened, like the resolve that you did,
did you develop from being that person
who figures your way through all those
problems? So like if so
if you got married now,
like you're a different
person like you, you could,
you'll figure shit out better now.
It's like, yeah, yeah, yeah. You also,
you also learn how to communicate better
so that it doesn't devolve to a point
where either you were being
malicious to each other. Yes,
me and my goes way better communication
than any of that I could have imagined
with anyone in my twenties yeah. Because
of those experiences and learning.
Yeah. Yeah. That's, that's the part
where you try to fucking correct within.
There's always a piece of you.
It's like, do you ever find that,
I guess I can't ask you
this as a married man,
but you find yourself sometimes looking
at past relationships like jokes where
you go, Oh, I know how I could've
fixed that. Oh yeah. For sure.
Yeah, please. Sure.
What the knowledge you have now
of relationships and love. Yes.
I can look back on stuff that I fucked
up and go, all I had to do was this,
this boom, and that joke woulda
hit. Yup. That would've been damn.
Yeah. So that eats like the way,
like when you do a TV set and
you forget one part, the joke,
and now for the rest of your life,
that's the set. That's who you are.
If there's a piece of you that's going,
fuck, I should have done that, man.
Yeah, but that's
of growth.
It's like you have to leave behind
these poorly finished projects to,
to appreciate the one that
you're gonna put out next.
That's going to be the best version of
it. I look at every fucking special.
Every did go. Even if there
was successful, I just go,
I don't have nothing to do with
them. I can't watch them. I've,
I fucking get disgusted.
My first two special should be
combined into one. I'm like,
I can literally look at the material
go, Oh, that's segues with that.
Yeah. Cut that out. Put
this in there. Yeah. Yeah.
And then there's old
specials that I said, Ooh,
I'd like to have another crack at those
ideas because those are good ideas.
I just didn't implement them
correctly. So move on. Kinda move on.
Yeah. If the idea is still valid
and working in insult. Yeah.
You get trapped, you trapped in old
ideas. It's out there. It's done new shit.
Find something new that resonates
just as well in the future as,
as this stuff does to you when
you're looking at the past.
I dunno,
I feel like I have some unfinished
thoughts from the last special of course,
but that, that desire and that hunger
is what makes you a great comic.
Like that. That's not done.
Oh, I've got gotta do more. Oh,
this is gotta be better next time.
Or I may make it tighter and make this
better. More punchlines, less less fat.
All that's
what that discomfort an adjunct
is. What makes you an artist.
That's why I like trying to do stuff
that has some teeth or some edge or some
opinion to it. You know,
trading and stuff that I don't
know if you should go with it. No,
let's go there. Let's figure it out.
There's, there's a joke in there. Somehow
when you can navigate those waters
successfully, it's like, fuck man.
You get on the other end
with a big laugh. Ooh,
whitewater rafting. It's, and there's
just rocks coming and you're going left.
Right?
Like does the guy calling out how to do
the joke and you're just navigating your
way down the rocks and if you
make it, it is the most rewarding.
Dismounts that for me is
better than just some in more,
but yeah, something more mundane
I had just, I can't do it.
Yeah. Yeah.
When you see people that do in the same
mundane shit over and over and over
again, you, they don't know what it's
like to have that thrilled. They're,
they're basically getting on
a fucking Seesaw every day,
the same Seesaw over and over. And
there's no thrill in that. No, no.
You're not four anymore. There's this
too many good thoughts out there. That's
why I love talking with Neil Brennan.
Like Neil Brennan is like one of those
perfect comics that I can like go,
Hey man, what do you think about this?
And he'll tag it darker and take it
to a place that I wouldn't have even
considered. And you know, like you
start noticing like there's only,
so even if you have a
bunch of comedian friends,
there's only certain France and understand
how or which way you're trying to go
with a bit.
Cause someone else might give you a tag
that drifts off into easy land and I
don't want it.
Right, right, right. Yeah. No.
Neil's a great joke writer and his,
his shit like I like his, I like watching
him workout premises cause you know,
you can tell him like he's put some real
thought into those ideas. Yeah, it's,
it's an, it's a thesis statement.
It just happens to be fun.
Like he's really breaking shit down. Yeah.
I liked the ones where I know that it
was an argument that he had with a girl
that he's bringing it to the stage and
try to work it out and make it funny.
Cause if you have an argument with a
girl and then she comes to see you at a
comedy club like a month later and that
argument gets relayed to the audience
and it's fucking hysterical.
Oh you win. That's how you win.
You win and you fucking slam dunk.
That is a fucking grand slam.
That's shatters windows in the parking
lot. I've never had the courage to do it.
I never had the courage to
perform material in front
in front of somebody I was
dating. Never done it.
No, it's hard. You gotta,
you gotta take a chance and them being
really mad at you when you get off stage.
I'll give you an example.
Like Wilson events is another guy that I
like talking to out in New York and the
premise,
the joke premise is that there are
no hit video games sit in Vietnam.
Like that's how much we don't want
to. That's true. Explore Vietnam,
world war II and middle
East is just the hits.
We only want to discuss the hits
where we won. That's a good point.
There've been games envy of course
there's some video games in Vienna,
but as far as hit popular
Twitch level Ninja shit, right?
None in Vietnam.
And then we'll submit a told Willis event
supremacy and he goes that and he says
that's because if you plan
a game based in Vietnam,
you can't win even if you want to.
Even when you win you still lose.
And it's taking that thought and
figuring out how to weave that.
But like that's what I mean where a
friend can help me work through an idea.
But then somewhere come,
the trick is to come around the backside
of that and make sure that you're
reinforcing and uplifting the people that
chose to fight and like I'm trying to,
yeah, it's a whole world that
I'm just obsessed with. I dunno.
And it all boils back to the whole Trump
draft Dodger thing and the hypocrisy
that if we agree that the troops are
fucked and they're treated horribly,
then how is draft dodging
bad and that being the,
the thought and [inaudible]
for Vietnam, correct war,
we all agree was a terrible war.
We didn't know it at the time
and some people chose to go,
but a lot of people were threatened
with jail that they didn't go.
So if you did not go based
on revisionist history,
was that not a solid decision
in terms of avoiding?
And so it's about getting that thought
through without disrespecting the heroism
of what happened. So tricky
waters, this fallen tree,
white water rafting baby rocks. So
I haven't figured it. Those are the,
those are the basic Lego blocks and I
have to figure out how to get down the
river without fucking hitting a jacket.
Do you write in like essay form?
Do you write things out like with
a computer? Do you, do you write,
once I have the ideas together,
I'd just go loose on stage. Um,
I'll go, I'll just run a bit a couple
times on stage without any structure,
without any real structure.
Just bullet points here.
The four points I want to make. Do
that for a week. Listen to the audio,
the stuff that's hot transcribed.
And then from that transcription start
filling in the blanks of how to flesh out
the thought and the point a
little bit more like I like,
but then some stuff requires
research. There's a bit,
that is a bit that I'm
working on now about how,
how the most important person,
the most important character in a civil
rights movie is the white person is the
evil white actor.
You cannot have a powerful civil rights
movie without a white person being evil.
So these actors are never honored.
They're never nominated for shit like
civil rights movies only as powerful as
the white actor.
He is evil because that captures what
was fucking happening back in that day.
Right?
So I need to like sit and physically go
to box office mojo and look at the last
10 years of civil rights movies versus
civil rights movies versus white savior
movies and pull actors and pull examples
and then look at their and then go to
their eye MDB and look at their trajectory
post civil rights movie to establish
a pattern of if you're a white
person, you do evil, your risk.
Cause my arguments that
you're risking your career.
If you're not an alias
actor and you plan a racist,
you may not do shit else at the, because
for black people, if you say n***a,
it's too real.
So we can't see you as a fucking Romulan
in a star Trek movie years later we're
unable to process. So, so that joke,
I have that idea and I'll just work
that thought a couple of times.
But now before I put it on
stage again, I need movies.
I need examples to back
the thesis statement.
So that's what I'll start writing and
really start looking at all of these
examples. And I also have like,
it's in the same ballpark of that is
about how like people call it like green
Greenblatt,
like a white savior movie and how this
movie is about white people doing a D D
for black people back in the day.
And black people don't like white
savior movies because you know,
it avoids the pain and the
struggle and all that shit.
And I feel like white savory movies
are just reactionary to powerful civil
rights movies cause nobody wants
to be portrayed negatively.
So if there are enough civil rights
movies that play white people as evil,
it's inevitable that a white person
is going to write a movie about.
Remember at a time we drove
you around to play the piano,
that it's inevitable. We, we
fit your chicken when we drove.
So don't just say all that. Don't just
show all those evil things we did.
Let's also acknowledge the
time we drove you around.
And I think if I go back and I looked
through the history of the box office over
the last 20 years,
I guarantee you I'll be able to find
an oscillation between powerful civil
rights movie and white savior movie.
And when you write that out and you're
just going to write bullet points and
then just run it on stage right
now we'll,
we'll do bullet points of all the movies
and then so the next stage is I'll do,
I'll write all those movies out and
I'll go on stage and do half of those
movies. One set,
the next set I'll do the other half of
movies and see which ones resonate the
quickest with the audience because
they're not all going to be timeless
classics. Some of them are
going to be deep in the woods,
but like Mississippi burning or like
Malcolm X and driving miss Daisy.
Those are two perfect examples of
conflicting films in the same year.
So I need iconic examples like that
where everybody knows the movie. Correct.
What? I haven't even seen it.
Yes. So that's trial and error.
So that just has to go on stage a couple
of times and then once I know what the
movies are, then we write it.
Then you verbatim that shit
it really fucking get it work.
That's black belt level comedy. That's
black belt level. It's like you have to,
you have to have like this is not
something that's obvious in front of you.
You have like a scaffolding and you're
trying to construct this and figure out a
way that it squeeze the most
juice out of it. That's,
that's that whitewater rafting.
That's it's so it's so rewarding
when that gets pulled off.
I just feel like if you look at every
genre and it's not to defend a white
savior movie as much as it is to just
show why the fuck it happened. Yeah.
This is about black people in the nineties
like boys into it in the 90s that was
the era of shoot 'em up bang,
bang hood classics and somewhere around
95 96 black cinema became much more
positive and reinforcing and it was
waiting to exhale and poetic justice and
above, not above the realm.
What's the other one? Um,
loved Jones and love and basketball.
Like there were all these more positive
black centers that was indirect reaction
to not wanting to be perceived and
portrayed constantly in a negative light.
So I could probably go deep into the
fucking weeds race by race on sentiment.
Like I could do all the Asian movies
and end with crazy rich Asians as the
counter to that. But it's not necessarily
Asian savior. Like there's no way,
I don't know how to connect that.
But I believe there is a way with all
of these cinematic movies to connect it
all together.
And at that point you probably got a
25 minute bit that you know needs to be
chopped down to 10 to 10 but
that's how you build all that.
You build the whole house and
then you just start chopping off.
And when you do that are
you writing it out? Do you,
do you ever write things out? Was
while I was asking as a forum,
cause one of the things that I've found
that has a great benefit as I write
things out, not trying to be funny,
instead of just writing it out in
a way where I'm trying to be funny,
I just write it out. Like
I'm writing an essay,
like I'm writing an article for a
magazine and then in doing that I'll,
I'll extract chunks that are funny because
I find that when I'm trying to write
as a comic, I'm trying to write,
set up punchline. It's too defining,
it's too limiting. But when
I write in an open form,
then funny ideas are in there and
I just come out and pull them.
Do you think,
do you think part of that is having the
advantage of the audience being with you
immediate? Like when
you have your audience,
you're afforded that opportunity to,
cause it's weird because the
way we build material now,
I don't think that's how you
did it when you first started.
Was it more about just the
joke, the joke, the joke?
Yeah. You had to be, you had to
gain their confidence, right.
That was the thing is like
you have to start strong.
You have to have a good opening bit.
You couldn't fuck around two months.
They had have confidence
in you. Like this guy,
this guy kind of waste my
fucking time. You know, they,
they just see if you're on a show, when
you're in a, when you're an amateur,
I mean fucking 10 other people
before you, you have to grab them,
you got to grab them,
you've got to grab them and show
them that you have something. Yeah.
But then once you become
an established comedian,
the other problem is you're working with
a bunch of other established comedians
like say if I'm working with you and
then there's Joey Diaz and you know all
these other fucking people that are going
on that are murdering and then you go
up with some bullshit new stuff
like that stuff has to be ready.
Like having an established audience is
great for a couple minutes and then you
better have some shit. You know? It's
almost like they have, there's more.
So things have to be more tight,
but some people don't do that.
Some people don't do clubs anymore where
they're working with a bunch of people.
They don't do like the store or the improv
where they're working with a bunch of
people. Instead they do their own shows,
they do their own shows only they have
the same opening act all the time and
then people there to see
them and it's a low bar.
They don't have to worry about it as
much. I think that's, that's a mistake.
But I think the essay form, I started
figuring that out maybe 10 years ago.
I started writing things in essay form.
I originally just do it as blog posts.
I would write blog posts and I'd take
those blog posts and I was extract ideas
from them and then make it into comedy.
But I feel like the writing without the
limitations of it needing to be funny is
where I'd get the most ideas.
Yeah. And then you also have
the most truth in theirs.
Yes. Cause I'm not just trying
to bullshit people for a laugh.
I'm trying to find out,
like what is it like if that
premise of the white savior movie,
like what is it about why
people making these moves?
Like what are they trying to, are
they trying to defend something?
Are they trying to exonerate themselves?
Like what are they trying to
do when they make that movie?
Has it just a feel good?
Is it their distorted idea of
how to bring everybody together?
Is it show that some white people
were really good back then? Yeah.
Even in the bad times. Look, great
movie. Hey, good job Michael.
You know, good job. Well like everybody
did a great job in this movie.
Like what, what is it that, that's the,
the motivation you could find, you know,
you find those, those gems of
humor, those roots of humor in that,
yeah, that's what I'm, that's what I'll,
I'll, I'll try that. I'll try writing,
writing and out more before putting it off
writing that way. Cause I don't have
to do anything. There's no expectation.
Like it just, it just thoughts.
Just spill the dots out and then
you get absorbed in the writing.
And then in that absorption
you're, I mean you're a funny guy.
You're always going to
think funny thoughts.
Those funny thoughts are going to come
out when you're talking about something
like and what the fuck
was this guy thinking?
And then you go on this whole rant about
this thing that maybe if you didn't
give yourself the opportunity to sit in
front of a computer and just stare at
the screen and stare at those keyboard,
you probably wouldn't have
come up with that premise.
Also. Um, once I have the
joke in a decent shape,
even if it's kind of loose,
I start watching myself on mute performed
like I go from audio to wants to joke
as structure to video and
then just watching myself
on mute and just seeing body
language and just seeing
does this look funny?
Does this look? That's interesting.
I've never feel for, and,
and I think you just had it once once
identify where my comedic trends where
it's quick, spastic movements,
but not a lot of stage talking.
Walking the stage doesn't work
for me. I'm not Chris rock,
so operate in like a three foot box to
either side of center stage and if it's
quit in hit, but nobody, if I,
if I take my head one way then bring my
shoulders instead of bringing my head
and shoulders at the same time on
a turn is if I'm caught while I'm
contemplating a point.
Something as simple as that for me helps
jokes and then I can go back and listen
to the audio at the back on,
watch the video and see where I'm getting
laughs just off movement and I haven't
said a word yet and for me it's quick
movements and facial expressions.
Those are the extra little I caught at
the extra season and that's the shit
that, you know, once you kind
of get the joke in a good place,
where can we add a little season
and is it a vocal inflection?
Is it coming down on this
part? Is it looking this way?
Then look in that way for the like,
like almost borderline performative,
like on some acting shit,
but just looking and finding places
where the emotions can change and not
necessarily on this line I do
this thing, but it's just, Oh,
this part is funnier if
I'm not as excited here.
That Foxworthy says some
shit I was watching and bring
the funny and he told one
of the contestants, eh,
if you started at 10 it's when the
competition comedy show the new show,
it's last comic standing. But with
sketch comics mixed in there as well.
So it's not, it's not strictly stand up,
it's sketch and variety acts
and all of that type of shit.
But the same shit you go out
in front of three judges,
somebody crushes your dreams and then
you talk shit about it behind the bags
once she kicked off the show. Uh,
but he tells somebody wants you started
at 10 you have nowhere else to go.
So I tried to keep that in mind in terms
of just not being too big too soon with
the material. Just shifting gears.
It's, it's a fascinating process.
And we discussed this on the show many
times before that there's no books that
can tell you how to do it.
The only way you get liked,
one of the things that's really cool
about this conversation is young guys
coming up, young girls coming up,
they want to learn how to do comedy,
can listen to your process and
they'll get an idea of the map ahead.
They'll get an idea of the
road because there's real,
there's no courses you can take
that are ever going to prepare you.
You have to find established comedians
and listen to them talk about how they do
it and in a sense what we're doing is
we're laying down like a sort of a a
course for,
for the up and coming class for the people
that are starting out now that don't
really have anyone to
show them how to do it.
They can cut a lot of time
out by listening to a guy
like you who is explaining
the mistakes that he made and then the
good choices that you made and then your
process.
I tried,
one of the tricks that I had early on was
to just avoid topics that anybody else
was talking about. And then even
if the joke wasn't the funniest,
I got credit for being original.
And I don't know if this
will work for every comment,
but I know coming up early two thousands
in the back half at a Def jam era to be
a black comic,
there wasn't talking about fucking and
sucking and weed and you have the been so
Brogan, like I just, I didn't
touch none of that shit.
So to a mainstream Booker
it was just, Oh wow.
He did a joke about suicide.
Okay, well let's look.
Yeah, look Kim,
well there's such a triplet jokes
that it was just weird off-brand shit,
but still finding funny in that this such
to pick on tried and Truven tried and
proven subjects because you know that
work, you know, and you're
scared in the beginning, right?
Yeah. You start, you see,
I feel like you start as a
weird image. Like my early,
my first few years of comedy was
this weird Martin Lawrence, Doug,
Stan hope hybrid child. Like, I dunno,
it was terrible. It's very terrible.
But I started noticing that when Blake,
the first thing I needed to do with the
first objective when I got on was to,
all right, all the road bookers
say you got to get a TV critic,
you get to get a TV credit and
then I can pay you more. All right.
Well the only thing that was booking
people on irregular was comic view.
So BTS comic view became the path,
but then I didn't get comic view like two,
three years in a row and
I looked at the material,
I submit it versus the material
that was being performed.
It was guys doing better versions of
the same topics as me. So all right.
This year we're going to try doing
different topics from everybody.
So I watched comic view for a whole year,
kept a log of every topic that was touched
on for every episode and just never
did jumps about those topics. Wow.
So you actually wrote it out. Yeah.
Every week. Come of you
came on every night though.
I remember back in like 2000 2001 come of,
you came on Monday through Friday
and it was six comics and episode,
so every week you had a cross section
of what 40 motherfuckers were talking
about. Wow. For 12 weeks. And
that's a shit ton of comedy.
That's a shit ton of topics
and you'd be surprised.
There's a lot of repetition and overlap.
So by simply not talking about that shit,
it's enough to get you a little bit right.
It's no different than what's
happening now with the alt scene.
You're just a different delivery.
You're a different cadence.
You have a different look.
Being different is almost as
important as being funny now. Yes.
I don't think that one, I don't
think they'd be in different,
should we prioritize over being funny?
But if you're different and you're
fucking hilarious, then you,
yeah. People appreciate it for sure.
Just like any other John rhe of art,
whether it's music or cinema, anything
being different is, is rewarding.
That's why I've always liked
emo Phillips, man. Really? Yeah,
that's what I came on. Well,
I just wanted to do the,
and the cadence was never
typical. Right. That shit
just, I'll say, all right.
That's at minimum it's different.
So he's challenging himself,
so I'm going to try that feels long. Yeah.
Dio Vaughn's got Theo comedy, like
Theo complex. You can't imitate that.
Like the only way that shit works
is if it comes out of Theo's mouth.
It doesn't even make sense
coming out to someone else.
CEO gets a laugh on,
he gets a laugh on the setup and he gets
a laugh on the pause and the pause is
that anticipatory gate
like you already know.
They already know what's going to be
good and they should go out there to get
the ah, yeah. Like he's,
he's good man. Yeah, he's real good.
And I watched that guy turned a
corner man about two, three years ago.
He just hit his groove and he went full
mullet. Wow. He had a mullet before,
but it was, he just found that groove,
like whatever it is that made
him, he found what it is.
They found the frequency and then
he just hit into it. And very, very,
very original.
You'd never hear him talking about like
stuff that other people have talked
about. There's a New York guy like that,
Martin Norman. Martin Norman has a way.
Sure. A lock. Love Mark.
Norman pivot is coming on soon.
He's up as on here a couple
of weeks. He's great.
Norman just knows how to pivot in a way
you think is going this way and it's
just a basketball crossover. Very good
writer. Very good writer. Well, listen,
man, I've got to wrap this up, but uh,
this is awesome. I really appreciate it.
I'm glad we finally did it. Thank
you so much. It was awesome.
Thank you Joe robe. Enjoyed
your work for a long time.
So glad to have you on
here, man. You know,
when the Vietnam joke gets worked
out, let it know. Let us know.
All right. Bye buddy.